et bienvenue au figaro toute la journée
les rédactions du figaro ont couvert le
premier tour de ce scrutin du des
législatives 2022 et ça va continuer
toute la soirée puisque dans un peu
moins d'une heure à 20 heures vous aurez
les premiers résultats et les premières
tendances de ce premier tour tendance
qu'on va vous dévoiler en direct depuis
le grand studio du figaro où vous vous
trouvez déjà vincent roux absolument
sharon des résultats qu'on va découvrir
commenté avec vous brûlez avec vous
chers internautes vous commentez dans lé
chat vous commentez dans le chat de du
site de la homepage du figaro bien sûr
et également sur youtube et maintenant
vous pouvez nous voir
surface le projet de télé connectée
développé par samsung
nouvelle soirée électorale à suivre sur
figaro live c'est parti
[Musique]
alors les premiers chiffres de
l'abstention les premiers chiffres qu'on
pourra donner et qu'on peut donner ce
sont les projections l'abstention en
tous les cas selon l'institut ifop 53 %
d'abstention vous même vous êtes vous
abstenus est allez vous voter et bien
vous nous le dites vous nous dites en
direct on va commenter tous ces premiers
chiffres avec judith waintraub grand
reporter au figaro magazine bonsoir judy
yves thréard directeur de la rédaction
du figaro et présentateur chaque mardi
du club le figaro politique 23e édition
à suivre mardi bien sûr avec notamment
comme invité arnaud benedetti il y a eu
déjà comme invité au club le figaro
politique judith waintraub mais aussi
c'était moi ce plaisir faites honneur
plaisir partagé bonsoir céline on le
voit de vous retrouver et on rappelle
que vous êtes directrice générale de
doxa qui publie chaque semaine avec
backbone consulting un sondage on y
reviendra justement dans l'est dans les
minutes à venir mais d'abord direction
la newsroom du figaro où on retrouve
bruno dre avec albert et nous rédacteur
en chef et chef du service politique
tout à fait je suis à côté donc d'albert
et nous le rédacteur en chef du service
politique du figaro bonsoir albert est
ce que vous nous expliquer quel est
votre dispositif pour couvrir une soirée
électorale alors c'est un dispositif
assez particulier puisque on est tous le
service politique mais également le web
et tout journal travail pour ceux pour
cet événement très important mais pour
le service politique donc tous les
journalistes sont là et on prépare ce
qui est un peu un exercice un peu
particulier c'est que nous on boucle le
prenez la première édition à 21h donc on
ad on a des résultats qui sont pas
définitives donc on travaille beaucoup
sur des estimations on a commencé déjà à
voir des estimations et donc tous les
journalistes ou les rédacteurs sont
partis déjà sur des hypothèses qu'on
essaye de de
crédibiliser de trouver des choses est
ici essayé de donner pour que demain
dans le journal on est les nos lecteurs
et compris quelque chose c'est ce qui
est toujours difficile c'est ce qu'on
boucle avec avec un temps un peu en
décalage donc mais on est on est on est
sur le pont et on est tous à téléphoner
à avoir des renseignements et j'ai
trouvé l'information la plus juste et en
général on y arrive vous avez publié
récemment donc une carte avec les 100
points chauds à suivre pour ce premier
tour de ce scrutin est ce que c'est sur
cette base que tous les journalistes du
service politique vont travailler ce
soir
notamment sur cette base on a été on va
essayer de déterminer les 100 points
chauds donc les ministres les candidats
un peu emblématique ceux qui ont des
chances ou pas de passer ceux qui ont
qui ont un enjeu particulier ce qui
représente un symbole dans cette
élection et essayer de voir ce que ça
pourrait être alors c'est une des bases
mais ce n'est pas seulement ça on essaya
aussi d'avoir une vision un peu plus
globale d'avoir donné les rapports de
force entre les parties est-ce que macro
aura une majorité absolue ou pas c'est
ce qui c'est ce qui est l'enjeu
principal est ce que la nuit baisse donc
l'alliance de gauche de autour de
mélenchon peut faire un score voire être
être majoritaire pas le plus probable
mais c'est peu c'est envisageable donc
on travaille sur toutes ces hypothèses
et la base nos sens nos 100 points
chauds comme on les appelle c'est très
important parce que ça donne une idée
répartis sur l'ensemble du territoire de
ce que pourrait être la prochaine
assemblée et combien de pas juste en une
phrase combien de pages en assure les
législatives demain on un jour nages on
a douze pages ce qui est un bon à bord à
sion merci albert et nous et n'oubliez
pas si vous restez avec nous jusqu'à 23h
alexis briser le patron des rédactions
viendra nous dévoiler en direct la une
du journal demain matin alors restez
bien avec nous
vous avez la raison d'être avec vous
puisque vous voyez nous avons céline
bracq avec nous ils thréard et judith
waintraub on commente avec vous les
premiers chiffres officiels de cette
élection pas officielle mais les
premiers chiffres qu'on peut vous donner
c'est celui de l'abstention
53 % yves un premier commentaire c'est
assez conforme à ce que tout le monde
disait est ce que l'institut de sondage
aussi disait toutes les études d'opinion
disait qu' il y aurait une forte
abstention bas on est dans le on est
dans je dirais dans cet ordre d'idées la
avec
si on
inverse la formulation 47 % de
participation c'est-à-dire parle
beaucoup pas beaucoup c'est une tendance
lourde maintenant de des élections en
france de tous les scrutins de scrutin
ce que tu as même pour les scrutins
nationaux eh bien il ya une forte
abstention et le fait alors il ya moult
raisons beaucoup de raisons mais il ya
aussi le fait que d'installer des
législatives justes dans la foulée de la
présidentielle pas comme la
présidentielle est un est un acte
important de la vie politique après bas
beaucoup de français estiment que
ces jouets qu'ils n'ont plus besoin de
se déplacer pour aller voter salle la
table mais c'est comme ça oui on a quand
même le sentiment que s'il y avait eu un
peu plus de campagne d'abord la
mobilisation aura été meilleur ça c'est
pour les raisons conjoncturelles en plus
des raisons de fond qui va viennent
évoquer et qui sont évidemment les
premières c'est à dire que tout se joue
à la présidentielle le rôle du parlement
depuis l'inversion du kaki d'or en 2002
a été quasiment réduit à néant
le balad a été achevée avec
l'interdiction du cumul des mandats ce
qu'il faut rappeler que non seulement
cette interdiction du cumul
donner des députés complètement
déconnectés du terrain mais en plus que
ça renforce encore le lien de dépendance
j'allais dire de sujétion vis-à-vis de
l'exécutif puisque un député dès qu'il
n'est pas puissant sur son terrain bah
on peut menacer de ne pas investir le
faire battre quand on veut 53 %
d'abstention tout cas c'est l'estimation
à qui est donnée notamment par
cet uniforme ce soir certains instituts
donnent un peu moins mais enfin on est à
0,1 ou 0,2 point prey sar est en tous
les cas un record oui ce serait un grave
c'est à dire que ce qui s'est passé
c'est que depuis
1988 petit à petit on voyait la
participation bcbc m'avait plutôt
tendance à s'effriter pour les
législatives et en 2017 il y avait
vraiment un effondrement là on a perdu
presque dix points de participation
et là ça voudrait dire qu'on irait on
renforcerait encore cette tendance et
c'est effectivement ce que nous avions
prévu notamment dans le dernier sondage
qu'on a on a pu guibal gbagbo consulting
et le figaro on était dans un étier
entre 43 et 49 avec un chiffre moyen de
46 % et on voyait que les français qui
nous répondait nous disait à la fois
qu'il s'intéressait de moins en moins la
politique et que par ailleurs cette
campagne en particulier ne les avait pas
beaucoup intéressé mais l'intérêt de
moins en moins fort pour la politique
c'est quand même ce qui ressort c'est à
dire qu'on on commence à voir pour
l'abstention des raisons qui sont
structurels de gens qui nous disent pour
l'essentiel quand on leur demande
pourquoi ils ne votent pas et bien je ne
vote pas parce que je ne vois pas du
tout le lien entre la vie politique et
ma vie à moi et les autres nous disent
que il ne s'intéresse pas du tout à la
politique et ça cette tendance là elle
est quand même assez récente parce que
la plupart des français jusque là ses
intérêts c'est quand même assez bien à
la politique est sans doute que depuis
2010 est avec la désaffiliation qui a
été très largement on va dire presque
favoriser enfin même par le président de
la république il ya sans doute aussi ça
qui fait que les gens s'intéressent plus
très bien plus beaucoup à des élections
qui au delà de la présidentielle alors
est-ce que vous avez voté est ce que
vous êtes abstenu pourquoi avez vous
voté pourquoi vous êtes vous abstenez
bien dites le nous ça va être
intéressant de confronter justement vos
commentaires vos réactions avec ce que
l'on peut observer en tendance lourde
dans à travers les sondages et les
sondages qui seront faits ce soir
d'ailleurs sorti des urnes qui pourront
nous donne également des indications sur
qui à cet absolu qui a voté et quel
impact ça a eu sur sur 7 sur cette
élection juste j'aurais qu'on regarde un
petit peu les enjeux pour chaque
formation qu'ils sont
qui sont en lice pour cette élection
la majorité pour l'instant et
de la majorité présidentielle c'est ce
qui correspond à la coalition ensemble
même si lors du prochain d'autres
précédents succès comme scrutin elle ne
s'était pas présenté comme ça comme ça
quel est l'enjeu pour elle ce soir c'est
à ces derniers c'est un scénario là du
tout les ans toutes les pour toutes les
formations politiques mais là en
l'occurrence pour la
majorité présidentielle c'est évidemment
de gagner et garder la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale tout le problème
est de savoir si c'est une majorité
relative ou une majorité absolue et que
si c'est aussi savoir si cette majorité
absolue c'est une majorité qui est
constitué uniquement par le parti du
président de la république s'appelle
renaissance ou avec ses partenaires qui
sont modem mais agir et puis tous les
ans
sachant que ces deux pour elle l' île il
ya un autre enjeu peut-être c'est qu'il
ya quand même pas mal de ministres qui
sont en lice oui c'est vrai il ya quinze
membres du gouvernement sur les 28
ministres donc c'est un enjeu de
crédibilité aussi c'est à dire que il ya
une règle qui a été instituée maintenant
de
nombreux toits la règle non écrite a
bien sûr ce n'est pas dans la
constitution mais les ministres qui se
présentent doivent gagner l'élection
sinon ils sortent du gouvernement il ya
quelques ministres qui sont d'ailleurs
sur des
circonscriptions qui sont qui sont pas
évidentes donc ça c'est certain que
c'est un enjeu pour ses membres du
gouvernement pour certaines
personnalités aussi il ya des enjeux par
exemple pour richard ferrand qui est
candidat qui souhaiterait être de
nouveau
nationale est bon alors à priori il est
bien parti en bretagne un an sont son
fief du finistère pour eric zemmour qui
se présente mais elle lui pour le coup
dans une circonscription qui va être
très difficile donc seront garanties de
prêt évidemment les circonscriptions
il ya aussi d'autres enjeux pour des
personnalités de la majorité
présidentielle présents christophe
castaner le reportage yao publiés
vendredi ont montré que c'est pas c'est
pas facile parce qu'il ya quand même la
concurrence de la gauche en particulier
du ps ou des nippes oui tout a été
organisé et par emmanuel macron et par
jean-luc mélenchon pour que ces
législatives soient leur face à face
face à face qui explique en partie à mon
avis n'est pas passionné les foules
d'autant qu'en guise d'arguments on a eu
droit d'un côté comme de l'autre des
imprécations d'ailleurs quand on
interroge les gens leur désaffection
leur lassitude devant le spectacle
politique et beaucoup due à la tonalité
de cette campagne la main si évidemment
cela c'est un mouvement de fond ça de
cette polarisation et c'est durcissement
qui est accompagné d'une absence de
débat parce qu'en gros est bien une
bague on nous a expliqué qu'elle avait
pas grand chose ce sera la catastrophe
et vice versa donc
[Musique]
à chaque à chaque scrutin sont sourds
d'épouvantail
c'était baring le pen à la
présidentielle là c'est jean luc
mélenchon la question que vous me posez
pas du tout celle là pardon sa mère
était choquée sûr que stoner mais la
réponse que vous m'apportez était très
intéressante de georges marchais mais on
veut pas faire bientôt parler de la
gauche radicale mais je voulais parler
comme si christophe castaner qui se
présentait dans la première
circonscription de hull d'autres c'est
un pilier de la macro ni fils laden
parmi les fidèles on se rappelle qu
emmanuel macron a eu beaucoup de mal à
s'en séparer au ministère de l'intérieur
alors même qu'il avait totalement perdu
la confiance des forces de l'ordre et en
particulier des policiers
inoccupés nca éminente au parlement
puisqu'il était à l'assemblée puisqu'il
était à la tête du groupe donc c'est
vraiment un test autre test il vise à
peine bornes dont c'est la première
tentative
à l'assemblée nationale fait longtemps
qu'un premier ministre d'ailleurs et
n'était pas candidat
en tous les cas un premier ministre en
lice n'était
candidat en 2017 la grosse nouveauté
c'était celle-là pourquoi castaner c'est
un peu compliqué parce qu'il est dans le
lubéron populaire il est dans le luberon
où la gauche a toujours été forte c'est
comme ça et d'ailleurs il lui c'est un
ancien socialiste il est à l'origine que
la première fois qu'il a été élu député
il a été élu sous les couleurs du parti
socialiste puisqu'il avait d'ailleurs
diriger la liste socialiste aux
élections origines régionales ou
économique en 2015 en paca où il avait
été d'ailleurs il s'était retiré pour
faire barrage à marion maraîchers dans
cette circonscription emmanuel macron
est tout juste vainqueur au second tour
si l'on peut dire puisqu'il était à 56 %
et marine le pen à effet presque 26 %
des voix au premier tour sachant que je
ne m'abuse c'est une circonscription où
emmanuel macron au premier tour est
arrivé troisième
derrière le marché
en tout cas on a aux électeurs de cette
circonscription qu'on salue par ailleurs
pour nous et pour nous bien nous
confirmer que c'était les bons chiffres
et puis si vous voulez vérifier il y a
également le moteur de recherche sur le
site du figaro qui est alimenté par le
fig data qui fait un travail colossal
pour pouvoir vous tenir au courant des
résultats à la fois dans votre
circonscription et des résultats dans
votre commune sachant que à 21h50 il y
aura un live spécialement dédié à la
question quel est le résultat chez moi à
quel est le résultat dans la
circonscription sera animée par thibaut
gauthier et adrien brillant en parallèle
de ce live avec nos invités les grandes
plumes du figaro et les meilleurs
politologue de la place de paris comme
céline bracq on va aller en coulisses
dans les coulisses du figaro retrouver
bruno dray qui se trouve avec quelqu'un
très importante en tout cas une personne
capital si vous voulez lire demain le
quotidien le figaro qui va être bouclée
dans quelques heures maintenant
oui tout à fait je me trouve aux côtés
de hannut est donc la directrice de la
rédaction adjointe en charge de
l'édition bonsoir anne bonsoir brune
alors elle va nous présenter un petit
peu son équipe qui est divisé en trois
groupes un petit peu à cet étage donc on
va la suivre sur les images de raphaël
la dre on va d'abord voir quels services
alors on va diriger d'abord vers le pôle
image donc le pôle image c'est donc il
est donc fait deux du service photo qui
est là on a des iconographes le patron
du service photo le directeur artistique
pierre bel qui est là donc y ajoutent le
côté créatif à nos pages et le service
imagerie qui traite les photos hockey et
on retourne sur nos pas donc avec sur la
droite je crois les correcteurs c'est ça
on l'a tous les correcteurs qui qui
essaye de trouver la faute et qui nous
rendent de la copie impeccable
et dans le fond maintenant je vous
montre tout l'ensemble du secrétariat de
rédaction dont ce sont les gens qui font
la mise en page du journal qui vont
réaliser toutes les pages pour ce soir
et qui vont donc le faire sur trois
éditions une édition à 21h donc dans une
heure un peu plus d'une heure et demi
maintenant une édition à 23h à une
édition à 1h travail pardon ils
travaillent tous sur la base du chemin
de fer on appelle ça dans le jargon
journalistique dans le jargon des médias
est ce que vous nous montrez à quoi ça
ressemble en avant première et nous
expliquer comment ça fonctionne en
jambes et le fils pardon
je vous montre le chemin de fer d'abord
sur papier donc c'est celui qu'on a
qu'on a faits qui était que j'ai sorti
vendredi soir sur lequel on avait déjà
travaillé sur les pages politiques en
fonction un peu des résultats des
sondages donc on a déjà préparé pas mal
de choses ne sont que des maquettes il
n'y a pas d'article on a un petit peu
avancé sur les deux autres cahiers
puisqu'on a le figaro économie et le
figaro et vous hélas si vous regardez
sur mon écran aujourd'hui eh bien il
s'est rempli ça c'est le figaro économie
bas toutes les pages sont remplies elles
sont parties le troisième cahier le
figaro et vous est parti aussi la fin du
journal international sport si on se
sente et j'en passe et des meilleurs
tout est parti et ne nous reste plus
maintenant qu'à remplir ses 12 premières
pages pour finir l'édition et envoyer le
journal à l'imprimerie et la une à les
déterminer à quelle heure la une elle va
être faite entre les 20h45 et 21h de
renier carats pour envoyer la page ok
merci beaucoup à nu est on vous laisse
travailler donc on comprend bien que
votre temps est précieux avoue vincent
roux merci beaucoup brune merci pour
cette petite découverte des coulisses du
figaro et merci à anne huet première
édition du figaro édition papier en pdf
aux alentours de 21h et puis bien sûr
une édition qui sera réactualisé
tout au long de la soirée que vous
pourrez découvrir en kiosque dès demain
matin dès les premières dès la fin de la
nuit d'ailleurs
on a commencé à évoquer le match
mélenchon macron donc il ya un enjeu et
c'est sans doute le phénomène de cette
campagne cette union de la gauche de la
nuit paix ce qu'est ce que peu
quel est le qu'elle met le curseur pour
la nuit ps soit est-ce que ils ont fait
ce qu'ils peuvent espérer gagner et s
que
ils ont pas déjà gagné en faisant déjà
cette alliance attend derrière attendant
les résultats mais
évidemment qui veulent gagner ils
veulent gagner en voix c'est-à-dire déjà
de le gagner on voit que c'est à dire
arriver les premiers après ils veulent
gagner le maximum de députés possible et
l'ambition de du patron mélenchon
s'étaient effectivement d'obtenir la
majorité pour pouvoir être premier
ministre justement c'était son objectif
le coup de bluff médiatique qu'il a fait
il voulait que ce coup de bluff banon
soit pas que ce soit une réalité la
troisième chose c'est que même s'il n'a
pas cette majorité c'est d'être le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale c'est à dire
d'être fort d'avoir un groupe qui
forment je sais pas moi
150 200 députés et dans ce cas là alors
que chacun d'ailleurs
formeraient un groupe chacune des
composantes de cette union delà du ps
aurait un groupe à lui même à lui seul
pardon c'est à dire le parti socialiste
c'est à dire europe écologie verts c'est
à dire le parti communiste et les
insoumis et autre chose c'est d'obtenir
et ça c'est pareil c'est une coutume
c'est pas une obligation d'obtenir et
bien la présidence de la commission des
finances et ça c'est très important
ce qui évidemment tenir les cowboys les
cordons de la bourse c'est toujours
utile et surtout ça vous permet d'avoir
des informations je dirais de première
main et d'avoir accès à toutes les
informations y compris d'ailleurs les
informations qu'il faudrait pas qu'elles
circulent trop sur le patrimoine de vos
collègues à l'assemblée nationale sur
alors qu'elle oui c'est enfin telle ou
telle politique qui sont menées enfin ça
vous permet d'avoir beaucoup davantage
donc il est évident que si vous êtes
fort à l'assemblée nationale plus vous
êtes fort l'assemblée nationale plus
peser sur le débat et plus et bien vous
pouvez vous opposez précisément à la
politique qui est conduite par le
président de la république et sa
majorité
rôle que doit jouer d'ailleurs les
républicains moi je trouve pendant la
preuve dans le précédent quinquennat
parce qu ils étaient une centaine de
députés et les républicains étaient
tellement mal à l'aise après leur échec
hexion présidentielle de 2017 après une
espèce de 2,2 justement de deux centres
de gravité de la droite qui s'était
déplacé un peu vert
vers emmanuel macron on sentait qu'ils
n'étaient pas très à l'aise et qui
s'était pas d'ailleurs unis très uni
entre eux là ils ne seront pas plus
d'ailleurs à la gauche de mélenchon il
ya quand même des distorsions
alimenta ralliement autour et pour des
idées de mélenchon principalement en vue
d'une reddition
il ya quand même une vraie victoire de
la part de mélenchon c'est cool fm sénat
car la première fois que la gauche
radicale est le centre névralgique de
l'avant et c'est la gauche radicale qui
s'il aspire la gauche le
social-démocrate
c'est une victoire d'autant plus
éclatante que le combat n'a pas eu lieu
puisque cette soumission mélenchon au
candy aux conditions de mélenchon sur le
programme de mélenchon s'est faite de
peur de se compter dans les urnes donc
tout le monde ou à peu près tout le
monde il faut saluer carole delga la
présidente de la région occitanie qui
elle a organisé la résistance sous son
étendard qui n'étaient pas candidates
évidemment mais qui a soutenu les
candidats qui voulaient résister à ce
ralliement seront sans condition à
mélenchon évidemment l'enjeu est
extrêmement important pour mélenchon
et il veut souligner à juste titre que
la droite avait pas exercice qu'on peut
définir simplement par l'expression
capacité de nuisance
sous la précédente mandature nicolas
sarkozy que le figaro magazine interview
ce week-end qui parle pour la première
fois depuis la présidentielle dit
d'ailleurs que la droite
a voté à l'assemblée 70% des textes
présentés par la majorité présidentielle
donc là aussi c'est quasiment un rallye
mot ou une union en bonne et due forme
la droite ne voulait pas jouer le
blocage et l'opposition systématique
jean luc mélenchon l'assument
complètement loupé c'est le conseil ces
trois plans flair
et sa encore ça va contribuer à
continuer d'abaisser par le vent
en tout cas ça a eu un effet si je me
réfère aux derniers sondages au doc
savage bonne consulting sait que dans
cette campagne qui a été atone et atone
également sur les réseaux sociaux en
revanche on a remarqué que le groupe qui
a été très mobilisés en particulier
mobilisés numériquement mais également
sur le terrain ça a été ça a été la
baisse et ça a été le dans le sondage
les français considèrent que c'est la
nuit parce qu'a fait la meilleure
campagne et c'est vrai que c'est quand
même un exploit parce qu'il faut voir
que normalement la troisième place à la
présidentielle c'est pas du tout eu la
meilleure place il a réussi à faire de
cette défaite laisse du mal à imaginer
lionel jospin effectivement en 2002 qui
aurait dit je vais viser mois premier
ministre envoyée le truc ou même
ségolène royal nous aurons ensemble vers
d'autres victoires le sort de son délit
de son échec c'est vrai mais elle était
2e et pas troisième que faire de cette
place de troisième
une
tout son mouvement elle est fille
derrière autour de lui a laissé parler a
voulu parler de jean luc mélenchon tout
le temps tout le temps il y avait des
interviews présidentielles il parlait de
jean-luc mélenchon il a réussi jean luc
mélenchon à combler le vide qu'il y a eu
pendant ces deux mois entre le second
tour de la présidentielle
et ce premier tour des législatives avec
un gouvernement qui a été nommé trois
semaines après donc avec beaucoup de
temps mais ce temps là il l'a utilisé et
il a utilisé de manière très efficace en
réussissant même si c'est effectivement
très électorale ou électoralistes à
réunir la gauche autour de lui vous
attribuer sa hotte seul talent 2
de mélenchon peut-être une atonie
également un peu de mélange d'acteurs
non non il ya du talent il ya un talent
incontestable puis c'est un vieux
routier de la politique il sait très
bien c'est très bien y faire moi je
crois aussi que c'est pas uniquement due
à son talent je crois qu'il fait aussi
de la part de beaucoup d'électeurs de
gauche le réflexe vote utile c'est à
dire la nécessité de redresser la tête
de pas se laisser je dirais humilié par
effectivement ben électorat qui était
qui s'étaient détournés de la gauche la
seule chose qui est intéressant enfin
aujourd'hui la gauche à l'assemblée il
ya moins de 100 députés oui et moi dit
redit et ce qui est intéressant
justement c'était de voir avec cet
épisode là que cette fois c'est la
gauche radicale qui absorbe ou qui mène
la danse vis-à-vis de la gauche sociale
démocrate alors que sous la vème
république saab sort était le contraire
c'est plutôt le parti socialiste qui est
bien essayé d'emmener derrière lui le
parti communiste d'ailleurs pour mieux
l'étouffer et là c'est une certaine
revanche aussi de la part de l anp chose
que mélenchon qui vient du parti
socialiste et qui a toujours estimé que
le parti socialiste elle lui avait pas
fait leur place qui lui était dû bien a
toujours dit pas publiquement mais il a
toujours laissé entendre qu'il voulait
tuer ce parti
vous savez si tu es tout seul à la
présidentielle est c'est aussi ça qui a
favorisé la nuance quand même
apprécié
72% de la
pratique
là il y avait moi d'amour propre qui
pouvaient entrer en jeu pour éviter
cette alliance certes mais vous parliez
tout à l'heure de carole delga
présidente de la région si dany tout à
l'heure
est ce que le parti socialiste ira
jusqu'au bout de cette alliance on voit
qu'il ya quand même pas mal de
dissidence qui se présentent dans cette
cette élection est ce que c'est pas un
peu le maillon faible de cette alliance
alors quand on demande aux socialistes
pourquoi cette alliance et sk la
vocation est ce qu a la vocation à durer
en fait il ya des réponses diverses et
variées il ya des gens qui sont
profondément
je sais parce qu'ils considèrent comme
une trahison des idéaux républicains
mais ceux là ont claqué la porte du play
je pense
par exemple à bernard cazeneuve qui est
dit haut et fort qu'on pouvait pas
piétiner tout ce à quoi on avait cru
quand on était socialiste il ya des gens
qui trouvent la pilule amère mais qui
sont persuadés que une fois leur siège
sauver et reprendront leurs cliques et
leurs claques réglera dépendance et ils
sortiront esquisse extraits rendus joue
de jean luc mélenchon je pense que cela
se trompent
profondément dans la tête jean luc
mélenchon c'est une emprise qui a
vocation à durer et je veux construire
une architecture
dont il sera l'auteur exclusif
53% s'est pour l'instant l'estimation de
l'abstention yves thréard va nous
quitter avant de vous quittiez ce
plateau il juste une question qu'est ce
que vous aller guetter en particulier ce
soir comme tous mes confrères je vais
gaieté qui arrive en tête et puis le
match parce que c'est ce match là
effectivement entre jean luc mélenchon
et emmanuel macron qui ni l'un ni
l'autre d'ailleurs son candidat c'est
par procuration et puis quand même
j'aurais un regard particulier sur
l'état de la droite les républicains qui
a quand même été
humilié par l'élection présidentielle -2
5% est-ce que là ce qu'on a dit sur leur
ancrage local qui était qu'ils étaient
certains d'ailleurs c'est une certitude
est-ce qu'ils vont sauver les meubles et
ce qu'ils vont réussir à obtenir un
groupe qui soit de l'ordre de 50 à 60
députés alors qu'ils sont plus que sans
la menthe n'en est qu'à la nasa la
sortie des élections présidentielles
dont je disais oh là là ils m'ont idron
un groupe de trente personnes quoi pas
nous voilà merci beaucoup ils vont vers
ce qu'il met à suivre ça on va retrouver
bruno dray
qui est au deuxième étage 2
la rédaction du figaro dans une demi
heure maintenant vous allez connaître
tous les toutes les premières
estimations les nouveaux rapports de
force et vous pouvez les retrouver en
haut justement de juste au dessus de ce
player en haut du site du figaro depuis
donc sur la homepage du figaro où se
trouve à vous la voyez une brune
d'audrey
[Musique]
oui tout à fait et vincent je me trouve
donc à côté de frédéric picard frédéric
picard qui va se lever qui va se mettre
à côté de moi et qui est rédacteur en
chef au figaro en charge notamment de la
tranche du soir sur lepoint fr est donc
maître d'orchestre un petit peu chef
d'orchestre de cette soirée électorale
comment vous vous êtes organisé et
frédéric bien non c'est bien organisé
enfin j'espère
on reçoit énormément d'informations du
terrain de ce que vous disait albert
tout à l'heure au service politique avec
beaucoup de gens sur le terrain nos
spécialistes on essaie de donner tout ça
en temps voulu sur notre live quasiment
minute par minute et on va beaucoup
bouger ce soir pour que nos lecteurs
puissent avoir les informations en temps
réel justement on voit toute votre
équipe qui est derrière sur cette grande
table figaro est ce que vous pouvez nous
présenter un petit peu le rôle de chacun
alors le rôle de chacun c'est un peu
compliqué mais on va dire on va dire que
cette table
c'est sur cette table que tout va se
passer il ya damien et etienne qui sont
mes adjoints qui vont toucher tout au
long de la soirée qui suivent exactement
minute par minute ce qui se passe samuel
potier qui est là qui est le digne
représentant du le lien entre le print
et le web et savoir exactement ce que
l'on doit push et suivre des papiers
payant venant du print puisque vous avez
vu anne tout à l'heure sur sur le
digital mathilde qui s'occupe qui est en
lien avec la vidéo et qui nous dit
exactement quand vont passer les
candidats en direct pour qu'on les aime
puisse les mettre sur la home et puis
matilda évidemment qui s'occupe de la
home et qui gère tous les flux de home
tout au long de la soirée est au bout
adrien qui lui s'occupe des réseaux
sociaux alors on essaie d'être le plus
proche possible pour que ça aille très
vite et juste derrière moi il y à leur
actif qui s'occupe des de tout le live
et benjamins qui est en butte à blé qui
est comme moi régisseur de tout cela
pour ça fonctionne au mieux alors enfin
dernière question fred picard jusqu'à
quand jusqu'à quelle heure on va pouvoir
trouver de l'info fraîche sur le sur
lepoint fr toujours sur le figaro de
l'info fraîche toute la nuit évidemment
et puis demain matin les équipes de
marion sont là dès 5 heures du matin
pour les réactions pour savoir comment
tout ça tout ça évolue tout au long de
la journée merci beaucoup frédéric
picard je vous dérange pas plus
longtemps et quant à moi vincent je vous
retrouve dans quelques instants en bas
dans vos studios dans le studio du
figaro le grand studio à vos côtés pour
l' annonce des premiers résultats à 20h
a tout de suite à toute une brune la
place est libre on vous attend pour
effectivement donné ses résultats dans
un petit peu moins d'une demi heure
maintenant résultats donc les rapports
de force déjà et peut-être une première
projection sur la physionomie de la
prochaine assemblée quelques résultats
nous parviennent pour l'instant et donc
on sera en mesure de vous donner au
moins une tendance une tendance qui
peut-être s'affinera pendant la la
soirée peut être également les premiers
résultats dans certaines
circonscriptions trentaine de
circonscriptions santis sensible une
centaine d'hommes qu'on a identifié au
figaro vous pouvez les retrouver sur le
site du figaro je salue and deguigné qui
vient de nous rejoindre bonsoir anne
je rappelle que vous êtes journaliste au
figaro économie et auteur d'une enquête
absolument passionnante qui s'appelle
sur le capitalisme euros que c'est aux
éditions presses de la cité
ces thématiques du mot qui finalement ne
se sont pas trop imposé pendant la
campagne non un peu pendant la campagne
présidentielle on a eu quelques cas
emmanuel macron a quand même fait
quelques sorties disant que voilà il
était contre leur autisme valérie
pécresse était aussi à exprimer sur le
sujet eric zemmour bien sûr mais c'est
resté assez voilà c'est resté comme
amassé assez superficielle là il ya eu
un retour de polémique avec la
nomination du ministre de l'éducation
nationale on va voir moi je ne pense pas
qu'il faille penser qu'il faille
attendre des mesures très boueux venant
de ce ministre après par contre qui est
possible c'est que au sein du ministère
les enseignantes voilà les enseignants
les plus indigéniste qui sont sur cette
ligne vont se sentir pousser des ailes
mon avis c'est plutôt ça le danger je ne
pense pas que deux duos du ministère le
ministre va donner des inflexions mais à
l'intérieur c'est possible qu'en interne
les gens se sentent très libre donc
voilà on va voir on va suivre ça de sang
de l'éducation alors j'ai vu réagir à
une petite moue judith qui a un petit
peu moi
donc / / / / / pap ndiaye mission look
isme quand même ce qui est vrai j'ai dit
c'est que vous qui êtes une observatrice
assez affûté de ce genre de phénomène je
renvoie tous vos articles de vous
enquête dans le figaro magazine eux
c'est vrai que c'est pas des thématiques
qui se sont tellement imposé pendant
cette campagne jst native en particulier
alors même que la gauche radicale et a
le vent en poupe bas une partie du
hockey soit aussi
par le biais enfin dans dans sa
dimension
de leveaux qui c'est aussi un discours
sur l'islamophobie
française ça dépend de l'aide de films
voilà mais c'est vrai que c'est
difficile d'en donner une définition
très scientifique
ok ça se saurait mais en tout cas l'idée
que la france est pour reprendre
justement l'expression de pap ndiaye un
système
raciste enfin présente du racisme alors
il n'ya pas dix systémique il a utilisé
il n'a pas dit racisme dr il a dit il y
à du racisme structurel structurelles
merci c'est une forme de nuances dans
les cheveux et celle possible suivant
saab on reste quand même une borne dans
les églises des work que la france est
la digne héritière de son passé colonial
et continue d'opprimer les minorités moi
je trouve que cette thématique a été
extrêmement présente vous allez dire que
chez cdc dans le capital en paille
n'accorde pas une de jean luc mélenchon
la meilleure preuve c'est ce sondage de
l'ifop nous dit que 69% des électeurs
musulmans ont voté pour lui à la
présidentielle au premier tour on verra
d'ailleurs si ce phénomène se répète
lors de sept de ces élections
législatives
il y à un phénomène qui par contre
s'impose aussi qui s'est imposée pendant
cette campagne électorale et c'est ce
qu'a relevé votre sondage avec backbone
consulting céline c'est l'importance que
les faits divers récents pourrait jouer
dans cette élection oui c'est
précisément parce que les français et
les médias puisqu'il n'avait pas grand
chose à se mettre sous la dent on
vraiment sur le contenu de la campagne
et c'est parce que la campagne était un
peu faible en contenu que des faits
divers ou un peu pris toute la place
tout l'espace médiatique
et c'est vrai que dans notre sondage
quand on demande aux français si à la
fois les débordements au stade de france
les le fait que cette jeune femme ait
été tué par un policier lors d'un
contrôle et quel était le troisième fait
qu'on a beaucoup commenté tout d'un coup
de m'échappe
voient leur tour de france est bon bref
si bien sûr et bien sûr il à faire abad
et bien ces sujets là on a trois
français sur 10 qui nous disent ça
comptera dans notre vote est d'habitude
les français sont très peu nombreux à
nous dire ça parce que d'abord dire que
un fait d'actualité récente va compter
dans quelque chose qui est très
structurelles ça ne se dit pas beaucoup
mais la halle 3 français sur dix disent
bon après tout ben oui c'est des choses
auxquelles on pensera au moment où m un
album bulletin dans l'urne
guillaume roquette vient de nous
rejoindre le pôle figaro magazine et
seulement s'il vient de se renforcer
bonsoir guillaumin soit
53 % c'est le chiffre de l'abstention
selon les premières estimations 1 un
commentaire alors on vient de me dire
qu'il vient de baisser mais
il reste quand même assez élevé un
premier commentaire sur 7 entre les cas
sur ce volume mais sur sept ans oui le
comment dire c'est que quand on met un
peu ce chiffre en perspective et
comprend les dernières échéances
électorales en particulier législatives
on s'aperçoit que c'est un mouvement
continu donc je pense qu'il ya davantage
une fatigue démocratique une lassitude
un désintérêt que une volonté de
sanctionner les candidats qui sont en
lice pour cette élection législative
c'est donc on dirait une espèce de
sentiment général peut-être que je vais
vous surprendre mais on soit je trouve
pas ça dramatique après klaus
apparemment il serait plus à 51/100 plus
qu'à 53 % dont on n'est pas très loin de
l'abstention seul donc c'est que c'est
relativement stable et puis toute façon
en france les gens sont pas obligés de
voter donc s'ils veulent pas mal à la
limite tant pis pour eux les choses se
passent en dehors de le seul véritable
danger de l'abstention c'est que ça peut
poser un problème de de légitimation des
gens qui sont élus c'est à dire que
quand vous arrivez les moments
difficiles et voilà il y aura forcément
des des séquences qui seront plus
complexes que dos des réformes qui
seront plus difficiles et là il ya la
moitié des français qui de façon plus ou
moins consciente diront ah oui mais moi
cette majorité là je n'ai pas élu donc
je ne me sens pas
concerné
embarqué dans ce qui est en train de se
jouer
je ne vous avais pas encore lg également
aux chiffres de l'abstention à ce que
vous souscrivez est ce que vient de dire
guillaume oui je pensais vraiment le son
c'est l'enjeu des toutes ces élections
c'est le grand malaise démocratique et
l'abstention est quand même le premier
indicateur encore de la vague la place
de la politique dans la vie des cités de
nos concitoyens et qui se sentent
intéressés qu'ils ont envie de
s'exprimer qui sont concernés et donc
évidemment une forte abstention et dans
le climat social très tendu du pays est
toujours mauvais signe c'est ça que vous
guettez justement auquel
le rapport qu'il ya entre l'abstention
aux élections et les répercussions qui
peuvent avoir un plan social c'est une
colère sociale s'exprimer il faut voir
qui s'abstient évidemment la grande
question c'est qui représente les
classes populaires aujourd'hui dans la
classe politique la question est ce que
les gens vont voter c'est quand même
important c'est les fameux gilet jaune
c'est eux qui étaient sur livre sur les
ronds-points à ce qu'ils votent ce
qu'ils ont voté aux législatives sur ces
thèmes des questions essentielles pour
les prochains mois alors je vous donne
la parole à céline et après je vous la
donne à guillaume il ya une
socialisation quand même du vote c'est
quand même ce qu'on observe et ce que
l'on observé notamment jérôme fourquet
jérôme sainte-marie bien sûr depuis 2002
puis demain c'est à dire que le vote est
devenu beaucoup plus le fait de
catégories favorisées qui habitent dans
des grandes villes ou moyennes villes
plutôt dans les centres villes qui ont
tendance à plus voté que les autres et
de manière plus générale de tout il ya
quand même quelque chose un phénomène
qui est national qui est un vote
intermittents c'est à dire que jusque
donc 2002 2007 2012 et pas dans ces
élections on avait 50 % des gens qui
votaient au 4e tour hier les deux tours
de la présidentielle de tour de
législatives on est passé à 10% moins
quatre électeurs sur dix qui ont voté à
tous les tours présidentielle
législatives ça a baissé partout et en
particulier chez les moins diplômés qui
se sont sentis complètement à côté de
ces élections là et finalement aux
france on a l'impression qu'on a deux
élections qui sont encore très incarné
qui sont la présidentielle et les
municipales où les français votent de
moins en moins mais vote quand même et
toutes les élections qui se font plus
sur étiquette ou là les gens ne voit
plus tellement l'intérêt de se déplacer
guillaume intéressant ce que
souvent quand on commente l'abstention
on dit hein c'est pas un phénomène
purement français de les états unis
comme d'habitude ont dix ans d'avancé
sur nous et ça fait longtemps que là bas
il ya plus qu'à prendre un électeur sur
deux qui vote sauf que ça s'est révélé
exact jusqu'à quand rome parce que quand
on dit aux gens que quand vous votez pas
ils disent à ce que ça sert à rien parce
que le résultat de cette élection ne
peut pas changer ma vie est là on va
voir si c'est un élément
qui a un impact sur le score de jean luc
mélenchon mais justement la nuque elle
arrive avec cette promesse de changement
on est d'accord ou pas mais on peut pas
dire que c'est la continuation de la
situation antérieure ainsi on retrouve
monsieur mélenchon à matignon on atteint
accrochez vos ceintures et donc est ce
que cette abstention relativement élevé
c'est un signe que l'électorat populaire
notamment n'a pas accroché à cette
promesse de changement radical on va le
savoir dans quelques minutes oui il faut
se rappeler aussi que pendant la
campagne
cette assemblée nationale affaiblie pour
des raisons qu'on a évoqué
institutionnels la version du calendrier
etc et en plus victimes de tentatives de
contournement annoncé et j'en citerai
deux en particulier une des manuels
macro avec son conseil national de la
refondation de rats tout et n'importe
quoi mais des institutions qui
fonctionnent mal comme les syndicats des
citoyens tirés au sort et là le
contournement de l'assemblée deviendra
officiel que ce conseil national de la
refondation devra si on écoute le
président de la république réélu jouer
un rôle premier dans l'élaboration des
grandes réformes et puis la deuxième
possibilité de contournement a annoncé
c'est celle de jean-luc mélenchon et de
ses affidés je pense notamment à
clémentine autain dix ans peu après le
deuxième tour si les législatives ne
nous donne pas le résultat escompté il
faudra aller le chercher dans la rue
ont tous les cas si vous venez nous
rejoindre
les derniers chiffres de l'abstention
son de 51 5% des voix 7 en tout cas
l'estimation qui est fait en les moins
fort que ce qu'on vous annoncer aux
alentours de 19 heures j'en profite pour
saluer jean paul claudius qui nous
rejoignent sur le chat du figaro et
toutes nos excuses sur youtube on a eu
du retard à l'allumage mais le chat est
ouvert et vous pouvez continuer à réagir
et je réagis je salue les abonnés de la
chaîne figaro live notamment quito et y
siam qui nous rejoignent ainsi que folle
qui me regardent du québec et bien
bonsoir volk a encore bon pour vous pour
l'instant ce n'est pas encore la soirée
et donc on vous souhaite une bonne
journée assure à vivre en direct bien
sûr sur figaro l'oeil et on savait bruno
dray bonsoir mon nom soit vous soir en
chair et en os dont soir à tous nos
invités voilà donc dans un peu moins
d'un quart d'heure maintenant on aura
les premiers résultats on pourra
commenter ce à quoi pourrait ressembler
l'assemblée nationale pour les cinq
prochaines années mais avance avant cela
je voudrais qu'on fasse un petit bond en
arrière il ya cinq ans guillaume en 2017
les républicains avaient décroché une
centaine de sièges un peu plus si on
ajoute les alliés de l'époque étaient
unis et en 2022 ils sont les grands
absents de cette campagne pourquoi ils
sont ils sont une seconde fois manifesté
on va dire viens parce que
ils ont pris un tel coup sur la tête
avec l'élection présidentielle et le
score de valérie pécresse que ils ont eu
du mal à s'en remettre c'est la première
raison et ils se sont dit à tord ou à
raison de toute façon faire campagne
nationalement ça nous réussit pas donc
on fait le service minimum à paris et ce
sont les candidats qui sur place la
bourre leur circonscription profitent de
leur implantation haddad a quand même
quelques leaders laurent wauquiez xavier
bertrand qui sont allés soutenir des
candidats mais vraiment c'était une
campagne locale campagne de terrain puis
il y a à droite ce qui ne se passe pas à
gauche c'est à dire que les droites sont
complètement divisé et donc il n'y a pas
cette espèce de deux défaites souffle
que représente la nuque ou jean luc
mélenchon a réussi à
accaparer et revenir à lui toutes les
couleurs de la gauche depuis le parti
socialiste jusqu'aux écologistes et
cette dynamique à droite elle n'existe
pas et christian jacob pourquoi il ne
s'est pas prononcé on va dire c'est
parce qu'il arrête il termine son mandat
pourquoi alors partie des corps la
mélodie mais c'est vrai qu'il faut il
écouter très attentivement un pur pour
savoir ce qu'il ce qu'ils souhaitent
faire je pense que sans doute que
malheureusement il anticipe des
résultats qui seront pas forcément
extraordinairement brillant et que donc
il se dit ce n'est peut-être pas la
peine de de s'épuiser si les résultats
sont pas à la hauteur de nos espérances
et c'est un peu c'est un peu dommage
parce que électoralement c'est une c'est
une force qui n'a pas disparu
voilà c'est tout c'est une les
sympathisants de droite dans les
sondages on les retrouve encore mais il
ya eu un réflexe de vote utile est ce
que là il va y avoir à nouveau le
réflexe de vote utile avec ce formidable
épouvantail à moineaux qui est jean luc
mélenchon ou les électeurs du centre et
de la droite on leur dit ah ben si vous
voulez
mais si vous votez pas peut-être pour
les candidats d' emmanuel macron tout de
suite il aura du mal à avoir une
majorité et donc on pourrait voir
arriver l'extrême gauche c'est vrai que
c'est pas facile d'exister et de se
faire entendre pour la droite dans un
contexte comme celui-là on peut se faire
entendre mais il ya quand même quelques
voix guillaume quand même qui surnage il
ya encore bruno retailleau david lisnard
xavier bertrand eric ciotti même qu'on a
entendu pendant la campagne oui c'est
vrai parce que cela il peut être qu'ils
se projettent déjà dans dans la séquence
d'après et qu' ils prennent date pour
ddd rendez vous futurs vous savez que la
question va se poser de savoir qui va
diriger les républicains est ce que ce
sera le candidat naturel vanga 2022 1027
c'est loin sur ce soit pour voir dans
quel état est ce parti mais on a un peu
le sentiment que
la droite classique la droite de
gouvernement ne croient plus à un
véritable rebond comme si le maquereau
nice mettait une espèce de trou noir qui
avait absorbé l'essentiel de l'énergie
de ceux de ce parti pour résumer on va
dire les maquereaux nice et enfin voter
macron c'est le vote utile est votée à
leers et le vote inutile
en tout cas c'est comme ça que ses vues
par certains électeurs on va voir
justement si s'il allait l air en tous
les cas relèvent la tête par rapport
donc au camouflet subi par par valérie
pécresse aux élections présidentielles
elle et par elle et elle est arrivée en
tête dans aucune circonscription donc
est-ce qu'ils peuvent avoir des élus au
premier tour par exemple
ce qui était le cas jusqu'à jusqu'à
présent
en nombre de circonscriptions
ça devrait ce sera une poignée si tel
est le cas mais en tout cas il y a des
élus locaux qui pourront faire de très
bons scores à priori parce que malgré
tout même si être député s'est pas
normalement c'est avant tout plus un
vote d'étiquettes qu'un vote de
personnalité et le député n'est pas
présent dans une circonscription comme
le maire les dans sa ville il ya quand
même un rôle que joue le député
maintenant je partage ce que vous disiez
on a une sous forme de défaitisme sans
doute lié au fait que
les catégories sociologiquement proche
de la droite les catégories plutôt
bourgeoise se sont dit au fond est-ce
qu'il faut pas aller voter pour éviter
une catastrophe mélenchonistes et que à
partir de là ils se sont mis à plat a
continué à avoir ce réflexe qui devient
un réflexe dans certains cas de voter
plus pour ensemble plutôt que pour voter
pour l air mais d'ailleurs l heure n'a
pas présenté de candidats partout je
sais dans ma circonscription je n'avais
même pas de candidat a l'air dans une
faute dans la 10e circonscription dans
les hauts-de-seine qui est les hauts de
seine c'est plutôt un département envoyé
quand même marqué à droite on ne pouvait
on n'allait pas sibilité si je ne
m'abuse c'est vers eux s'avèrent issy
les moulineaux
gabriela talent en fait que la droite
laisse complètement gagner enfin fief
d'andré santini mais justement je
rebondis sur ça il ya des des cirques où
il n'y a pas eu de candidat est là et
puis aussi des circonscriptions où il ya
des candidats et l'eire qui était
quasiment assuré d'être réélu et
pourtant ils ont choisi de changer
d'étiquette pour ces législatives
pourquoi ils ont fait ça je pense à eric
woerth dans l'oise où constance le grip
à neuilly pourquoi ils ont changé
d'étiquettes au dernier moment parce
qu'ils ont pensé exactement ce qu'a dit
nicolas sarkozy
on change les bus a fait l'interview
dans le figaro magazine ce week end
c'est à dire que je cite ouvrez les
guillemets nicolas sarkozy emmanuel
macron est la meilleure solution pour le
moment pour la droite donc c'est une
conviction qui est peut-être récente
dans le cas de certaines personnes que
vous avez cités si l'on s'en réfère à
leur déclaration est en tout cas c'est
comme ça qui explique leurs aliments il
ya un autre élément c'est qu'en fait
pour l'avenir la droite la bataille se
joue très partiellement à l'assemblée
nationale elle s'y joue un peu parce que
c'est l'avenir financier
qui va être
déterminé en tout cas pour un élément
pour une partie extrêmement importante
puisque vous savez que c'est le nombre
des députés qui est la principale source
de financement des partis politiques
mais sinon la bataille du leadership
tous les noms qu'on vienne cité des
personnalités qui ont malgré tout essayé
de faire un peu campagne au niveau
national que ce soit xavier bertrand
laurent wauquiez david lisnard bruno
retailleau tout cela
de tout cela aucun des candidats aux
législatives il ya le le futur enfin à
moins qu'un autre à petro émergent la
bataille pour le leadership de la droite
passera entre des gens qui ne siègeront
pas à l'assemblée nationale à une
réaction peut-être juste pour ajouter
pourquoi ils se sont ralliés parfois
simplement en effet pour s'ils gagnent
leur cirque o et puis souvent aussi en
espérant un marocain un gouvernement
bien sûr parce qu'évidemment l'exécutif
là on le connaît et un quelqu'un comme
eric woerth on peut penser il sait et il
l air ou en marche ça veut dire c'est
possible même que sur le terrain omnium
dans l'oise on lui fasse payer d'avoir
d'avoir passé chez en marche lui on
pense va je ne veux pas parler avec lui
c'est évident qu'il ya aussi un espoir
des promesses sans doute d il a des
convictions communes notamment
également sur sur le plan qui nous
intéresse au premier chef la chan qui
est l'économie oui et après c'est pas du
tout incohérent d'un point de vue de
politique économique de la part de
quelqu'un comme eric woerth qui est vous
qui était le président de la commission
des finances qui est proche de bruno le
maire de rallier en marche même si après
tant de décennies une infamie de doha tu
sais que c'était c'était un vrai coup
dur en pleine campagne présidentielle
symboliquement c'était voilà c'était une
vraie rupture
guillaume encore un mot et après on
passe au rassemblement national par
contraste le la dynamique que l'on voit
à gauche dont on verra si elle se
transmet depuis elle se traduit dans les
urnes par dont elle elle valide le
l'effacement de la droite parce que à
gauche pourquoi ça marche parce que
c'est les radicaux qui ont pris les clés
du camion à comme il n'était pas
question pour elles air de donner les
clés d'une alliance à marine le pen et
barils sont restés tout seul et tout
seul à côté du maquereau nice il
n'arrive pas existé nos beaux qu'ils
soient spécialement mauvais mais parce
que ils sont pas suffisamment différent
pour que les électeurs effectivement
voient la nécessité surtout quand il ya
un risque d'extrême gauche en face une
2de de voter pour eux plutôt que pour un
candidat macro nist un jour mieux placé
on parlait justement de marine le pen
elle a été en tous les cas c'est ce
qu'on a dit dans les derniers clubs
politique du figaro l'une des grandes
des grands deux des grandes absentes un
peu de cette de cette campagne est ce
que quand même céline il y avait eu des
élus au premier tour du recensement
national le front national d'ailleurs en
2017 est-ce que là c'est encore
envisageables notamment pour marine le
pen oui c'est envisageable pour marine
le pen et c'est envisageable que le
front national face ce que le
rassemblement national pardon face un
score qui lui permettent de battre ou
d'égaler le record de 86 ou 35 députés
étaient entre elles à l'assemblée
nationale scrutin proportionnel à
l'époque à ce critère est donc beaucoup
plus favorable que le scrutin
nominal actuelle
par circonscription donc vraiment
aujourd'hui c'est vrai que marine le pen
ne s'est pas engagée dans la campagne où
elle s'y est engagée c'est très
tardivement avec aussi on parlait de
défaitisme pour les républicains un peu
de défaitisme aussi dans la voix de
marine le pen qui est partage avec les
républicains le fait du coup d'être ne
pas avoir d'alliance ni avec les
républicains ni avec reconquête est
d'être dans une situation qui est moins
favorable que celle de la nuit passe
alors même que c'est bien elle qui de
manière forte et marquante est arrivé au
second tour de l'élection présidentielle
donc c'est vrai que pour marine le pen
ce sera on verra bien ce que ça donne
mais les derniers sondages donnait des
résultats qui étaient qui lui permettait
d'espérer de faire de faire des bons
scores et de
pouvoir avoir un groupe et un groupe
fort à l'assemblée nationale mais sans
doute pas autant que ce qu'elle pourrait
espérer avec un problème quand même de
taille pour un certain nombre de
candidats de rassemblement national un
problème de notoriété et de normes
basses
compétents après un problème de bascule
une difficulté quand même pour le
rassemblement national de recruter des
cadres pour ces législatives
alors c'est vrai pour tous les nouveaux
partis ans c'était le cas pour la
république en marchant faut s'en
souvenir c on lira profite d'ailleurs le
vivre leur quête de walle bordas sur la
question
plus belle dès qu'il ya des déformations
qui sont en tout cas un peu restantes
pour parce que on ne peut pas dire que
le rassemblement national est une
nouvelle formation mais en tout cas
qu'il n'avait pas une stratégie très
très forte ces dernières années de
présence pour les élections locales et
et le bad boys a été particulièrement
concentrée sur sur certains candidats
certes certaines candidates du
rassemblement l'international
reste maintenant quatre minutes avant
qu'on vous dévoile en direct sur le
figaro live les premiers résultats de ce
premier tour du scrutin des législatives
on nous reste donc peut-être trois à
quatre minutes pour parler peut-être de
la révélation la sensation ou plutôt le
nouveau parti qui réussit quand même un
tour de maître lors de ces législatives
certains partis récent et il arrive
quand même à présenter un candidat dans
550 circonscriptions sur 577 donc même
s'il a peu de chances de remporter
beaucoup de sièges à l'assemblée est ce
qu'il a pas quand même gagné entre
guillemets en autres divinités week en
crédibilité pour un parti si jeune
d'envoyer quelqu'un dans 550
circonscription quand j'ai dit oui c'est
vrai que c'est une performance
le/la l'un des moteurs de la candidature
d'eric zemmour c'était de mettre le
sujet migratoires au centre du débat
présidentiel de ce conduit là il a
réussi pendant les deux ou trois
premiers mois de campagne et après le
sujet quasiment totalement disparu
céline vous parliez tout à l'heure des
faits divers qui avait pris une
importance énorme dans cette campagne
dans ceux que vous avez cités il n'y a
pas par exemple
le drame arrivée à sète cette femme
septuagénaire violée par deux algériens
en situation irrégulière en france le
fait divers avait traité par la campagne
a été très ciblée donc le thème de
l'immigration a disparu des ces deux
codes d'autant plus une performance dans
ces conditions là puisque finalement il
a échoué à imposer le thème au centre du
débat de réussir à présenter des
candidats partout
eric zemmour
guillaume pelletier peut-être ces deux
candidatures à suivre pour
dit naturel alors dans le cas de
guillaume pelletier c'est normalement un
peu plus facile que et en sorte que le
candidat tueur d'eric zemmour et
exerçait un vrai challenge de pouvoir
éventuellement réussir quelque chose
dans sa circonscription déjà s'il
réussit à se qualifier ce sera déjà très
fort et on a donné pour le second 4e
circonscription du var donc la
circonscription de saint tropez
19h58 et 17 secondes dans un peu plus
dans un peu moins de deux minutes
maintenant on sera en mesure de vous
donner les nouveaux rapports de force
issus de ce premier tour des élections
législatives est également de vous
donner peut-être une première mais une
toute première physionomie de ce que
pourrait être l'assemblée nationale à
partir de la semaine prochaine
je rappelle le les estimations de
l'abstention
51,5 % c'est peu ou prou ce serait
beaucoup en tout cas si le chiffre sont
confiants le taux atteint lors du
premier tour de
2017 il nous reste une minute peut-être
un tour de table qu'est-ce que vous avez
gaieté en particulier dans les résultats
qui vont être donnés judith la première
chose c'est qu'ils arrivent en tête
est-ce que la nuit mélenchon réussit son
pari d'être la première force
d'opposition
deuxième chose est ce que qui est en
situation d'atteindre la parfaite il dit
des 289 sièges à l'assemblée nationale
qui permet d'avoir une majorité absolue
donc de déterminer qui sera le premier
ministre vient je vais d'été aussi le
score de la nuque mais en particulier le
pourcentage de voix c'est à dire est ce
qu'il y a au delà de l'intelligence
tactique de jean luc mélenchon qui a
réussi à agréger autour de lui les
autres forces de gauche est ce qu'il ya
un désir de gauche plus important cette
fois que lors des précédentes
législatives où le lac le total des
gauches faisait 24 7% de mémoire and je
regarderai la nuque bien sûr mais aussi
peut-être voilà est-ce que la droite
s'en va rivard peu à rebondir après
c'est le score de valérie boyer pécresse
à la présidentielle ce qu'on retourne
bien 15 20 pour ce pas je ne sais pas ce
que voilà dans quelle mesure la droite
existe encore ou pas la droite classique
et là on va le savoir tout de suite ça y
est les résultats sont tombés nous avons
donc les premières tendances les voici
et c'est la surprise peut-être de ce
soir là ils paient ce qui arrive en tête
avec
25,7 pour cent des voire 25 % derrière
pour ensemble ce sont des estimations a
qui ne sont donnés par l'ifop on va y
revenir dans un instant suivi par le
rassemblement national avec 19,3 pour
cent des voix sur ses premiers ces
premières estimations et ensuite
viennent les républicains et leurs
alliés aux 11 6% des voix donc c'est
nettement plus que ce qu'a obtenu
valérie pécresse lors de l'élection
présidentielle même si c'est moins que
ce qui avait été recueillie en 2010 est
suivi de reconquête reconquête 4% donc
trois points de moins que pour le
scrutin présidentiel et puis viennent
ensuite divers droite à 3,7 dit r-
gauche à 3,3 pour cent et les divers
extrême gauche tout en bas à 1,2 pour
cent on va peut-être être en mesure de
vous montrer une première projection de
l'assemblée nationale avec le nombre de
députés selon le score donc on verrait
donc peut-être la majorité
présidentielle ensemble entre 275 et 310
députés tu ville donc de la coalition
denis pesce qui auraient entre 180 et
210 députés on le rappelle ce sont des
premières estimations entre 40 et 60
députés pour l air et autres 40 et 60
députés pardon pour le élèves une idée y
est on me rassemble la nation
rassemblement national entre 5 et 25
donc même pas sûr encore de faire un
groupe à l'assemblée selon cette
première projection tué viennent ensuite
reconquête entre 0 et 2 députés alors
une première réaction c'est à ces
chiffres guillaume
oui la news et le la majorité sont au
coude à coude le il semblerait que les
espoirs de jean luc mélenchon soit
douchez ce soir c'est à dire qu' il ne
sera pas le prochain premier ministre il
ya quand même semble-t-il avec les
projections qu'on a aujourd'hui qu'on à
cette heure-ci pardon à une différence y
est quand même très importante en plus a
priori comme les autres participations
est relativement peu élevé y aura peu de
triangulaires dont peu de surprises je
pense que même si la majorité des
manuels macron m et finir en tête il y
aura peut-être une petite un petit
soupir de satisfaction ce soir ni paix
devant en nombre de voix en revanche en
projection ils sont largement derrière
en nombre de sièges les premières
projections égal à 100 par les deux
premières projections peut-être céline
c'est que pour l'instant là on donne les
instits les chiffres de l'ifop mais
d'autres instituts de sondage donnent
soit en sortent ensemble un du ps au
coude à coude soit ensemble en tête
ouais voilà c'est ça exactement voirie
avril soit égalité soit toujours nous
j'ai à chaque fois on y passe plutôt
légèrement en tête les
pardons les estimations d lab et
et sel comme celle d'ifop et ipsos pour
le moment mais à égalité
las nubes est ensemble
alors finalement vous disais la surprise
mais c'est très très proche de ce qui
était prévu dans les estimations et mais
pas que pas de l'annulation en tête
oui enfin si elle l'est ce sera
symboliquement effectivement ça
permettra pas la surprise réelle aurait
été celle à qui aurait été la surprise
des coeurs est une très mauvaise
surprise pour les instituts de sondages
en l'occurrence par la juge nous on n'a
pas fait d'estimation donc ouais je
parle de manière parfaitement
indépendantes ça aurait été qu'ils
puissent faire un score qui leur
permettent d'obtenir la majorité est là
on en est quand même très loin oui un
autre élément c'est que par définition
quand on fait le rassemblement l'union
le ralliement au premier tour on n'a
plus de réserve au second puisque ça a
déjà été fait parce qu'il n'est pas le
cas du tout du parti des vannes une
macro et qui profite de qui profitera de
cette solution cette position centrale
pour
pouvoir justement récupérer des voix de
droite face à alan hippe sc des voix de
gauche lorsqu'il sera en duel avec le
rassemblement national après l'essentiel
est sauf effectivement semble-t-il un
pur pour emmanuel macron c'est à dire
qu' il n'y aura probablement une
majorité va quand même pas être sain
d'abord parce que symboliquement si
effectivement son parti arrive deuxième
on imagine à quel point il va y avoir
une
guérilla parlementaire de la nuque et
puis
le deuxième point c'est que avec une
abstention élevée et je pense que cette
petite musique de
le la légitimité pour accomplir les
réformes elle ne va pas ça ne va pas
s'arrêter et troisième point si la
majorité n'a pas n'a pas le nombre de
députés suffisant pour avoir la majorité
absolue
il va falloir s'allier donc ça aussi
c'est une petite épine dans le pied donc
globalement soulagé parce qu'à l'instant
guillaume l esat on va revoir la
projection mais bien entre 260 et 1975
entre heures ça c'est le rapport de
force mais si on regarde la projection
de l'assemblée nationale ce serait entre
275 et 300 10 sièges pour la majorité
ensemble 310 et la majorité absolue 275
c'est pas la majorité 80 n'a fait la
majorité absolue donc c'est vrai que là
il gagne plus la fourchette fait qu' il
est possible que ensemble n'est pas la
majorité et doivent proposer du coup
avec l air qui en dépit de ce mauvais
score ce de cette mauvais chiffres pas
se retrouverait à chaque fois comme en
position d'arbitré on a entendu des
leaders de l air ces derniers jours dire
qu'au fond ça leur permettrait quand
même de retrouver un rôle politique au
sein de l'assemblée nationale qui n'ont
pas eu beaucoup eu lors de cette
dernière législature de l'est à leurs
dons qui serait crédité de avec avec lui
dès qu'ils seraient créditées de 40 à 60
sièges
il y à une centaine de sièges pour
atteindre watts 131 mètres dans
l'assemblée sortante donc le en revanche
en termes de voix
l'evian salaires udi fait en tout cas en
termes de pourcentage en termes de voix
mais en termes de pourcentages fait
quand même mieux vaut mieux aller dire
que valérie pécresse à la présidentielle
là après je pense ça va tout dépend des
cirques ou l'ancrage local à des députés
sortants sera intéressant de voir mme en
versant dans une semaine mais un média
même ce soir devant les scores à des
idées à des uns et des autres mais c'est
sûr que la couleur de l'assemblée va
être
l'ambiance assemblée va être très
différente parce que toutes les filles
c'est vraiment confirmé et la 1re
opposition ce qui veut dire un questeur
une vice présidence a priori la
présidence de la commission des finances
qui dit présidence de la commission des
finances dit le droit d'aller à tout
moment à bercy demander tous les
documents qu'on veut et consulter sur
place notamment tous les documents
fiscaux donc et j'ai ça c'est ça c'est
vraiment je pense a priori ce serait
alexis corbière sans doute qui se
réfléchit pour ce poste ce qui veut dire
attention retour
non bloqué les projets de tous les
projets qu'il faut pas bloquer ils vont
là ça va être très compliqué mais
surtout la grande crainte j'ai compris
en bercy en ce moment c'est qu'il y ait
dans médi ils vont pas le ne sont pas le
sortir eux mêmes et dans médiapart tous
les quatre matins vous ayez les dossiers
fiscaux de beaucoup de contribuables
évidemment des plus riches des plus
aisés dessus fiscaux des entreprises
compliquée pour tous ces dossiers très
complets qui demandent de rendre de la
distance
discrétion qui sont traités voilà tous
les ils sont traités à bercy en ce
moment vous aurez potentiellement le
président de l efi de la commission des
finances qui pourra toujours regarder en
direct entre ces lignes de questions qui
sont posées par les internautes la
première c est ce que ces projections
tiennent compte des triangulaires a
priori vu le chiffre de l'abstention il
devrait y avoir peu de triangulaires de
mémoire il y en avait eu qu'une
2010 c'est ça exactement donc et l'aïe a
priori il en aurait pas
j'ai pas le détail pour le moment mais à
priori il n'y aurait pas de triangulaire
mais ça prend évidemment en compte ces
projections prennent en compte les
résultats si à chaque fois pour vérifier
si oui ou non une personnalité est en
position de se maintenir même si elle
n'est pas arrivée ni première ni
deuxième mais qu'elle a fait plus de 12
et demi pour cent des inscrits vous
inscrire voilà donc ce qui veut dire à
peu près 25% des voix pour pouvoir se
maintenir mais ça il faudra regarder
dans le détail avant de pouvoir vous
répondre précisément à votre question
pourquoi ensemble aurait plus de députés
alors que selanne us qui fait le plus de
voix voilà c'est ces décès dus à notre à
notre objection du second tour
c'est à dire qu'aujourd'hui c'est c'est
ce qui est dénoncé par par jean luc
mélenchon mais aussi marine le pen c'est
le fait qu'on ait un mode de scrutin
aujourd'hui qui ne permet pas à une
formation qui a réalisé un score
important à la présidentielle de pouvoir
être reflété refléter exactement au sein
de l'assemblée nationale parce que
aujourd'hui
comment dire ensemble et la nie pas ce
beau être au coude à coude et bien
ensemble rats probablement une centaine
de sièges supplémentaires et céliane
mode de scrutin tout cas du ps 1 nouveau
un nouveau sondage est en train de
tomber deux des nouvelles estimations
mon serait bel et bien en tête puisque
pour rebondir peut-être judith sur ce
que vient de dire céline il ya une autre
question ça va nous permettre de
commenter le un autre score une autre
projection qui donnerait quand même
assez peu de députés très peu de députés
même moins que ce qu'ils ont
actuellement ce serait pour le
rassemblement national
on est dans une fourchette entre 5 et 25
députés bien bien loin des 40 estimé
dans certaines estimations alors que le
parti fait qu'un arrive en troisième
position avec 19 2% à 6 points derrière
la coalition sas et les joies du système
majoritaire comme ces lignes viennent
expliquer sans alliance
scrutin majoritaire si vous êtes seul
vous êtes perdant forcément le
rassemblement national et reconquête
aurait eu intérêt à s'allier évidemment
évidemment maintenant la craste de
marine le pen était de perdre son
leadership sur la droite radicale c'est
pour ça qu'elle n'a pas voulu entendre
parler d'eric zemmour est la plus ou
moins a annoncé c'est d'ailleurs dans le
figaro que c'était cette dernière
candidature à la présidentielle puis
finalement c'est devenu beaucoup moins
claire on a très nettement l'impression
aussi que jordan bardella est prête à
bondir pour occuper le siège que marine
le pen n'a pas en n'a pas encore
abandonné ça va être évidemment cette
question de l'alliance des droites la
grande question de la prochaine
législature
parce que c'est vrai que d'après les
premières estimations la droite de
gouvernement fait mieux qu'à la
présidentielle puisqu'elle serait autour
de 11% on sait plus de deux fois le
score de valérie pécresse mais c'est
près de deux fois moins que son score de
2017 est donc cette idée selon laquelle
c'est vrai que la droite aurait du mal
au niveau national la droite classique
parce que emmanuel macron occuperait
tout l'espace mais que au niveau local
l'ancrage serait suffisant pour résister
ça semble être de moins en moins le cas
et donc qui va sûrement y avoir des
questions presque existentielle qui vont
se poser est ce que cette droite du
gouvernement elle peut continuer à
exister seul ou est-ce qu'il faut
qu'elle accepte d'être une sorte d'
annexe du maquereau nisme ou bien est-ce
qu'il faut qu'elle accepte d'envisager
une alliance avec les avec les autres
droites ça va être à mon avis assez
cholet et les instances de l air dans
les semaines qui viennent comment elle
pourrait rebondir là bas ça paraît
difficile parce que alors à moins 2 à
moins de vivre d'espoir ce qui est
toujours une capacité possibilité dans
l'existence en se disant ah oui mais
emmanuel macron ne peut pas se présenter
une troisième fois et donc qu'il n'y
aura pas de leader aussi charismatique
et peut-être qu'à ce moment là ce sera
notre chance mais tant que les
républicains ne savent pas sur quelles
lignes exact ils veulent être c'est à
dire ou bien une ligne de centre droit
espace occupé pour l'instant par macron
ou bien une ligne le plus plus
protestataire du bonapartisme et il ya
déjà grâce aux mots nationale et zemmour
ben je pense que ça va être compliqué
parce que pour se faire entendre il faut
quand même avoir quelque chose à dire il
y aura peut-être des recompositions
peut-être aussi avec horizon puisque on
sait que edouard philippe a priori a
quand même pas mal d'ambitions et le
président de la république ne pourra pas
se représenter pour un troisième mandat
et donc edouard philippe qui se dit de
droite qui se dit toujours de droite
pourraient se présenter pour la
prochaine présidentielle
du coup pour beaucoup de personnalités
de droite qui se sentiraient plus tôt du
centre droit il ya sans doute moyen de
pouvoir recomposée et comme la
république en marche pardon renaissance
va devoir un peu sortir de l'ambiguïté
maintenant parce que si il ya quelques
difficultés à obtenir une majorité
absolue et qu'il faut de voir par les
convaincre des députés de droite et donc
se montrer comme étant une formation
plutôt de droite ça va peut-être aussi
cela crée de nouveaux partis de nouveau
découpage pour la prochaine
présidentielle
des chiffres qui sera intéressant à
regarder mais qu'on aura peut-être en
tout cas un début dans le courant de la
soirée c'est le rapport de force à
l'intérieur de la majorité entre
précisément les tendances différentes
celle d'edouard philippe et celle des
bagnoles mac le fait que
justement l'on voit la projection quand
même est assez basse pour les pour les
élèves les udi alors que le parti donc
fait deux très ennemis 14 60 ce qui
n'est pas tellement éloigné de ce qui
est du score de 2017 si je ne m'abuse
puisque à l'époque il avait obtenu un
peu plus un peu moins de 10 9%
ça fait 1 5 fois 5 fois et demie le pape
c'est pas du pareil au même et notamment
est ce que à droite et
centre droite et centre est ce que
justement le fait qu' ils descendent à
trets et demi pour cent et que et que
surtout il soit on leur projette aussi
peut bien moins de députés en tous les
cas moi très plus de moitié moins
ça vient du fait aussi que un certain
nombre d'électeurs ce soir a donc au
risque de se dire également on va voter
d'électeurs de droite on va voter plutôt
la république en marche ou pour les
parties de
jeu pour commencer pour vous et j'ai vu
ses week-ends à voir des gens qui m'ont
dit ah mais peut-être qu'il faut voter
ensemble dès le premier tour c'est à
dire ma chronique pour éviter qu'ils
aient une majorité mélange lisse à
l'assemblée nationale là qu'on voit
l'efficacité extraordinaire du système
macron ça marche à la fois avec la
gauche et avec la droite au second tour
de la présidentielle ont dit à voter
pour moi sinon c'est l'extrême droite et
là autour d'initiatives ce sera à voter
pour moi c'est non c'est l'extrême
gauche eh ben il faut reconnaître que le
système est performant pour l'instant
semble-t-il
on va regarder de nouveau une la mise à
jour des débats projections du rapport
de forces est donc c'est une
confirmation goodrem c'est toujours là
mais parce qu arrive en tête avec ces
nouvelles données donc à 26,1 % ce sont
les chiffres de l'ifop toujours suivi
donc de la majorité présidentielle sous
la bannière ensemble à 25,6 pour cent le
rn recueillerait donc avec cette danse
est mise à jour 10 9 2% et là elle est
rude et y serait à 11,3 pour cent donc
c'est moins que ce qui est on avait
annoncé dans un premier temps et 4,1
pour cent pour reconquête le parti
d'eric zemmour qui fait quand même la
moins bien nettement moins bien que
son champion à la présidentielle
ça c'est un phénomène classique dans les
nouveaux partis oui complètement et
surtout hors scène incarné alors bon
déjà eric zemmour n'a pas fait le score
escompté dont il ya quand même une fin à
la présidentielle y pensez pouvoir faire
encore mieux je dirais encore mieux pour
un nouveau candidat puisqu'il a déjà
fait un score tout à fait tout à fait
bon pour un nouveau candidat et donc
cette déception a aussi un effet sur les
législatives c'est à dire que alors que
pendant longtemps on a eu le sentiment
que eric zemmour s'était lui qui allait
permettre à l'extrême droite pourquoi
pas d'arriver un jour au pouvoir et bien
a déçu les électeurs et du coup aux
législatives n'est pas considéré comme
une force permettant de renverser la
table ce que souhaite la plupart des
électeurs qui votent pour le
rassemblement national ou pour
reconquête pourrait donc dans les faits
voiture dans les faits vote utile qui
est un élément du vote ça ça ça compte
et elle a réussi à renverser la vapeur
en l'occurrence lors de la
présidentielle où finalement alors que
beaucoup pouvait dire marine le pen
s'est terminée elle a montré qu'elle
faisait encore un score qui lui
permettait de d'être sélectionné au
second tour est de retour et elle fait
si non non elle fait six points de plus
laurence joseph et six points de plus
assez ce premier tour des législatives
que que en 2010 est donc il ya une vraie
il ya une consolidation en nombre de
voix mais effectivement ça ne se
traduira pas en nombre de sièges alors
qu'a contrario même si c'est un succès
qui s'annonce assez spectaculaire pour
la nuque puisque elle arrive en tête et
elle sera de très loin le premier groupe
d'opposition 6484 480 circonscription
second tour des législatives
donc mais si on additionne les voix
il n'y a pas de raz-de-marée de gauche
en france ils sont autour de 26% encore
une fois je rappelle que a donc avec
tout toutes les gauches si si on
additionne ce qu'avait fait la france
insoumise le parti socialiste et
écologistes et les autres ça faisait 24
7% donc c'est un petit peu mieux mais
par rapport à à
ne pas dire au bruit ce serait
désobligeant mais par rapport à l'écho
qu'a eue la campagne de jean luc
mélenchon peut pas dire que ce soit un
bouleversement complet du paysage
électoral n'zi pacte nanou vous reproche
nos médias d'avoir été très impartiaux
qui on a voulu faire du sensationnel il
en fait la promotion de mélenchon mais à
une fois quand même dire une chose que
c'est ça c'est quand même ça a été le
phénomène de la connerie là et il faut
reconnaître qu'il a le grand mérite
d'avoir un programme cohérent différents
nettement différent de celui du
président il a créé le débat
voilà il avait un programme qui est
qu'il a travaillé qu'ils étaient sérieux
[Musique]
et l'enthousiasmé
sont mènera le paysan sérieux pas
financé c'est vraiment étonnant certain
mathieu montcourt et qui emmènerait je
me sens le pays dans le mur mais qui qui
du coup présenté un débat par rapport à
celui du président et du double intérêt
je pense et dsrack à la présidentielle
ont manqué de débats de débats de fond
il a profité d'ailleurs dû
est ce que justement ce vote est aussi
un vote pouvoir d'achat
il a vraiment profité aussi de 2 du fait
que qu'emmanuel macro et puis annoncer
un report de l'âge légal de départ à la
retraite
à 65 ans même s'il s'est repris ensuite
parce que alors que la problématique
pouvoir d'achat allait exploser par
rapport à l'élection de 2017 c'est vrai
qu'elle est arrivée quand même un peu
contre j'allais dire contre emplois mais
à un contretemps plutôt à contretemps et
jean luc mélenchon a pu mettre en valeur
à quel point lui il était là pour
pouvoir au contraire défendre le pouvoir
d'achat des français y compris des
retraités et donc ça c'est sûr que ça a
joué et en plus et même jean luc
mélenchon et celui sans doute qui a le
programme le plus clairement contraire à
celui du président de la république et
c'est pas si évident que ça parce que
pour pour les partis qui reste des
partis modérés il n'y a pas vraiment de
prise en fait
il n'y a pas d'opposition facile alors
que pour jean luc mélenchon au fond il
est plutôt facile de pouvoir prendre à
peu près tout ce que dit emmanuel macron
et de dire que lui il est sur une ligne
différente et donc c'est plus clairement
identifiés et ça donne plus envie aux
gens de pouvoir aller voter pour lui
mais dire sur les qui sont les questions
de pouvoir d'achat je pense que l'opposé
des bagues retrait autant alors le début
de la campagne présidentielle va eric
zemmour avait entraîné tout le monde
attend sur l'immigration là jean luc
mélenchon a entraîné tout le monde sur
le pouvoir d'achat emmanuel marine le
pen aussi oui quand même les thématiques
mais là du coup le président a répondu
en promettant mille et une mesure qui
vont arriver dans le projet de voir
pouvoir d'achat après le second tour des
législatives
et c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui en fait
évidemment non leurs couleurs leurs
programmes très différents il ya un fond
de marxisme très clair chez jean luc
mélenchon mais d'après le programme
présidentiel est tout sauf ce numéro que
sauf libéral on a des les lois qui
arrive de soutien au pouvoir d'achat
sont complètement ahurissante injuste on
s'endette pour allier et puy lancé la
consommation à court terme sachant qu'en
même temps la bce joue faire baisser la
consommation marine le pen est en train
de s'exprimer on va l'écouter
et amplifier leur vote au second tour
nous offre la possibilité d'envoyer un
groupe très important de députés
patriotes dans la nouvelle assemblée
nationale nous pouvons en effet espérer
nombre de députés pour faire valoir avec
coeur et conviction vos idées vos
valeurs et vos intérêts comme pour
défendre votre pouvoir d'achat ou votre
sécurité
dans notre pays en proie au doute et où
tout semble hors contrôle on le voit
avec le stade de france l'inflation ou
la hausse du carburant il faut des
députés solide et déterminé pour faire
valoir la voix des honnêtes gens celle
des entrepreneurs et des salariés des
familles et des retraités celle de
patriotes français qui souffrent de voir
leur pays dans cet état dimanche
prochain il est important de ne pas
laisser emmanuel macron disposer d'une
majorité absolue dont il abusera pour
appliquer ces méthodes autocentré est
brutal et nous imposer son projet
antisocial faire ce qu'il veut comme il
veut à votre place mais sans vous et
souvent contre vous si vous laissez
faire nous risquons d'entrer pour cinq
ans dans un tunnel un tunnel sans
lumière pour une majorité de français
cette situation sera peu respirable avec
des dizaines d'élus rassemblement
national vous aurez au contraire la
certitude d'être représentées par des
députés proches de vous une opposition
ferme mais respectueuse de nos
institutions et qui porte avec courage
un projet de redressement pour le pays
et pour le peuple dans les
circonscriptions qui voit au second tour
un duel entre la république en marche et
la nuque baisse javid les électeurs à ne
pas choisir entre les destructeurs d'en
haut et les destructeurs d'en bas
à ne pas choisir entre ceux qui veulent
vous priver de vos droits et ceux qui
veulent vous priver de vos biens la
france n'est ni une salle de marché nine
zad dans le cas où un candidat autre que
le rassemblement national ferait face à
un candidat lrm ou nubes j'invite les
électeurs à agir en conscience en
fonction du sens patriotique de ce
candidat
électeurs du rassemblement national
électeurs patriotes de droite de gauche
et d'ailleurs ayez conscience que la
séquence électorale n'est pas fini vous
avez un rôle essentiel à jouer vous
pouvez faire entrer à l'assemblée un
groupe national très importants comme
jamais dans l'histoire politique de
notre pays
ce sera là une immense victoire pour le
corps national pour le peuple et pour la
france cette victoire du camp national
est à portée de main et de vote je
compte sur vous vive la république vive
la france
voilà vous venez d'entendre marine le
pen dans une courte allocution qui
demande aux électeurs de confirmer son
score donc c'est à dire qu'elle n'a pas
été élu dès le premier tour dans sa
circonscription et puis elle a eu une
punchline si on peut dire la france
n'est ni une salle de marché ni une zad
qu'est ce qu'elle peut espérer qu est ce
qu elle peut espérer and pour le second
tour elle et elle elle joue la carte
voilà lé représente le parti national
écossais modo vous avez l'internationale
libérale et contre l'internacional
bolchéviques ici je caricature un peu
son propos duquel elle dit la ville
choisie c'est en fonction de 1,10 du
patriotisme sur 10 ans patrice en
statique mais là n'est pas le moins
d'opposition l'a22 par deux parties qui
ne serait pas patriote on voit les
projections on ne peut pas espérer grand
chose elle a ce qui est intéressant
c'est qu'elle alliance l'alliance des
extrêmes elle ne se situe pas du tout là
dessus cette ligne-là et le discours val
discours et et amusant elle tient sa
ligne mais je crois que les projections
sont assez claires là bas pour l'instant
justement au niveau des projections en
vue d'être au niveau du
du sort même de marine le pen à
inquiéter élus lors des prochaines des
précédentes élections dès le premier
tour à hénin beaumont là elle
dépasserait la majorité mais il
suffirait pas c'est à dire qu'elle
obtiendrait près de 55% des suffrages
mais comme il faut avoir un score qui de
25 % des électeurs inscrits et que la
participation serait très faible dans sa
circonscription eh bien ça pourrait
l'obliger à un second tour face à marine
tondelier qui est candidate europe
ecologie les verts de la ville passe
alors ça se joue visiblement a pas
beaucoup donc je crois que ce n'est pas
encore complètement confirmé qu'elle
devra avoir un second tour qui là pour
le coup présente peu de doute sur le
résultat jean luc mélenchon est un train
de prendre la parole on va l'écouter
ça y est c'est notre tour
maintenant l'émission encore perdu dans
mes papiers
mesdames messieurs
vous toutes et vous tous qui m'attendait
à cette heure
je m'adresse à vous avec toute l'émotion
que vous pouvez deviner
au vu du résultat tel qu'il nous est
annoncé
au terme de ce premier tour la nouvelle
union populaire
arrive en tête
elle sera présente donc plus de 500
circonscription au deuxième tour
et dès lors
les projections en sièges à cette heure
n'ont à peu près aucun sens
sinon celui de maintenir une illusion
puisse-t-elle finir d'étourdir nos
adversaires
pour le reste
la vérité que le parti présidentiel
au terme du premier tour est battu
et défait
pour la 1re fois de la 100ème république
un président nouvellement élu ne
parvient pas à réunir une majorité à
l'élection législative qui suivent
j'appelle notre peuple
au vu de ce résultat
et de l' opportunité
extraordinaire qu'elle présente
pour nos vies personnelles et pour le
destin de la patrie commune
j'appelle notre peuple
a déferlé dimanche prochain
bien sûr
pour rejeter définitivement
les projets funestes
de la majorité de monsieur macro la
retraite à 65 ans le travail forcé pour
le rsa et la partie cachée de son
programme qui n'a jamais pu être mis en
débat c'est à dire
et comme nous le savions et comme le bon
sens lundi qu' il est impossible de
retirer une telle somme d'un budget
c'est non seulement ce projet qu'il
s'agit de rejeter
mais celui qui va avec c'est à dire
l'idée d'une tva augmentée qui
permettrait de financer
ce projet
alors bien sûr il s'agit de rejeter
d'écarter
mais peut-être plus important est le
fait qu en déferlant en se mobilisant
tout et tout et d'abord dans la jeunesse
à qui le futur à partir et d'abord
dans tous les milieux populaires si
durement éprouvées par
les trente années de néolibéralisme qui
se sont abattues sur lui
déferler
déferlé avec vos bulletins de vote pour
ouvrir tout grand
la porte du futur pour lequel se sont
mobilisés tant de générations avant la
nôtre
ces futurs d'harmonie entre les êtres
humains débarrasser des domination
sociale culturelle de genre
un futur d'harmonie entre les êtres
humains et avec la nature
je crois que c'est sans doute
cette page là que vous avez voulu écrire
en votant comme vous l'avez fait vous
autres qui avaient placé la nouvelle
union populaire écologique et sociale en
tête
mais si vous le décidez alors oui dans
dix jours
les prix seront bloqués le smic sera
augmenté à 1500 euros
et le lundi des fonctionnaires
sera augmentée
dans un mois vous aurez la retraite à 60
ans débat
et peut-être avant cela la
titularisation des 800 milles
contractuels de la fonction publique
je ne cite que cela
mais c'est la façon que j'aurai ce soir
de rendre concret
et non politicien
la satisfaction que nous avons en
observant ce résultat qui est le
résultat d'abord d'un accord historique
celui qui a permis la naissance
de la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale qu en soient
remerciés tous
tous sans exception qui ont rendu
possible cet accord
et qui a fini par faire comprendre à
notre peuple que nous étions prêts à
gouverner
avec un programme
et avec une unité qui ne s'est démentie
à aucun moment quelles qu'aient été les
tentatives faites pour la briser
depuis qu'elle s'est constituée
la nouvelle union
populaire écologique et sociale
affranchi d'une manière magnifique
le premier test qu'elle rencontrait
mener campagne ensemble au coude à coude
et convaincre car en démocratie tout se
finit par là il faut convaincre nous
avons beaucoup convaincu
il reste maintenant à faire l'autre
partie du chemin
chacun appréciera dans sa
circonscription calé son devoir
en républicain en démocrate
et saura quoi faire de son bulletin de
vote
nous n'avons aucun doute sur
l'intelligence de notre peuple
ni aucune réserve à l'égard de la
décision que pour finir il prendra quant
à la composition de l'assemblée
nationale
c'est pourquoi nous demandons
à ceux avec qui nous nous sommes
affrontées au premier tour de regarder
ce deuxième tour
non seulement sous l'angle des projets
non seulement sous l'angle des
étiquettes
mais sous celui de l'intérêt général de
la patrie et de son peuple
en lançant cet appel
déferler décidé par vous même je suis
certain d'être entendu par des millions
de gens qui jusque là peut-être n'avait
même pas imaginer que deuxième tour il
aurait à prendre une décision comme
celle qui se présente à eux dans 500
circonscription
la nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale est fier d'avoir
rendu possible
son programme et les fiers de l'oeuvre
accomplie
elle regarde le peuple français
avec la tranquillité du travail accompli
et d'une perspectives radieuses qui se
présentent à lui
vive la république vive la france
mais d'entendre donc jean luc mélenchon
qui vient de s'exprimer une dizaine de
minutes on va revenir dans un instant
sur cette déclaration donc du chef de la
coalition danube est ce qui est arrivé
en tête selon les estimations de ce
premier tour des élections législatives
mais avant on va faire le point sur les
autres résultats ceux qui sont en train
de tomber dans certaines
circonscriptions il ya déjà des des
surprises timothée d'élèves et oui
vincent on suit évidemment les résultats
circonscription par circonscription les
résultats qui commence à arriver au
compte gouttes vous l'avez entendu sur
sur notre antenne marine le pen qui
arriverait donc en tête dans sa 11ème
circonscription du pas de calais avec
55% des voix ça c'est ce qu'elle a à
déclaré depuis son fief d'hénin-beaumont
et vous l'avez rappelé céline marine le
pen qui devrait malgré tout devoir se
continuer le combat disons au second
tour dimanche prochain à cause de la
faible participation elle sera donc
opposé à la candidate du ps à noter
également et ça c'est l'information de
la soirée l'une des informations en tout
cas de la soirée jean michel bancaire
l'ancien ministre de l'éducation
nationale et qui lui serait éliminé dès
le premier tour ça c'est une estimation
une estimation ifop tf1 il faut pour tf1
par dont 18% des suffrages donc pour
jean michel blanquer il arrive en
troisième position derrière le candidat
du rassemblement national thomas
ménagers qui lui recueille 31 6% des
voix et le candidat du ps bruno notin
qui lui arriverait avec 20% des
suffrages ça il s'agit de d'estimation
pour ce qui est des résultats officiels
on allait réduire de 2 les résultats par
le ministère de l'intérieur on les a
pour en ce qui concerne les territoires
d'outre-mer sachez que parmi les 15
ministres qui jouent leur avenir au
gouvernement la secrétaire d'état chargé
de la mer justine bénin est en
ballottage favorable
elle arrive en tête dans la deuxième
circonscription de guadeloupe et
recueille 31 avec 31% des voix dimanche
prochain à l'affrontera le candidat de
l'ani baisse christian baptiste qui lui
a récolté
26,78 % des suffrages exprimés
merci beaucoup timothée peut-être une
réaction d'avoir à ces infos et puis est
ce qu'on vient d'entendre de jean luc
mélenchon guillaume oui c'est compliqué
quand vous allez y arriver
oui c'est compliqué tout comme moi je
moi ce que je ce que je retiens c'est le
sait le ton de jean-luc mélenchon oui en
fait on est comme s'ils étaient éteints
alors et en plus il est pas très bien
éclairé donc ça ça n'est pas mais
très souvent à la télévision la chance
d'être dans le studio trion ce qu'on est
ce qu'on n'est pas plus fort que ce
qu'on dit est de toute évidence que là
il avait quand même l'air un petit peu
un petit peu
déçue de ce 2 de ce qui se passait en
réfléchissant à tous les éléments qu'on
vient d'avoir là je me dis que
finalement c'est pas une si mauvaise
soirée que ça pour pour emmanuel macron
il ya un point important quand même
c'est que finalement l'abstention ne
serait pas plus importante si j'ai bien
compris que en 2017 et que donc on ne
pourrez pas
contester davantage cette fois que la
fois d'avant là la majorité si majorité
il ya on verra ce que donnera le second
tour mais
ça même si symboliquement le score de la
nuque est importante je me semble qu'on
est plutôt dans un pack de soulagement
quand la majorité est une chose
profondément vrai qu'a dit jean luc
mélenchon au moins une c'est que les
projections en sièges alors qu'il est
telle qu elle fo fait faux très peu
fiable et non pas beaucoup de sens
j'irais pas jusqu'a dire très peu fiable
parce que oui parce que je lui dis
carrément que il peut complètement
renversé les prévisions qui sont faites
enfin vous êtes pressé le pas laisser
dans l'autre sens puisqu'il n'a pas de
réserve de voix voilà la mélasse l'aï
dit si vous le décidez vous allez
pouvoir là on va pouvoir appliquer le le
programme notre programme je vais en
effet pouvoir être premier ministre ça
peut expliquer aussi expliquer aussi
pourquoi je suis tout à fait d'accord
avec guillaume il avait l'air quand même
complètement éteint très loin du ton
extrêmement vindicatif qu'il avait au
soir du premier tour de la
présidentielle
et donc c'est vrai que l'on va tous nous
institut revoir circonscription partie
de conscription quand on aura des
résultats définitifs pour pouvoir pour
pouvoir faire les projections parce que
dans certains cas je pense que ça va pas
être évident de les faire ben parce que
il faut pouvoir avoir d'abord des scores
extrêmement précis même on parlait de
l'estimation sur jean michel blanquer à
deux points près il ne serait pas
qualifié
bfm utilise le terme de d'estimation
partiel bon donc vous voyez déjà il faut
être sûr de savoir qui est qualifié et
qui ne l'est pas et ensuite il va
falloir étudier chaque configuration par
rapport aux dernières législatives par
rapport à la présidentielle pour pouvoir
estimer chacune des circonscriptions
donc notre travail à nous pour l'instant
c'est pas ça qui est fait c'est quelque
chose d'assez automatisé qui est fait à
partir d'échantillons mais le travail
qu'on va avoir nos instituts maintenant
ça va être de le faire circonscription
par circonscription à la main c'est
comme ça qu'en fait on fait sérieusement
mais aussi une projection pour un second
tour gaccio il a déclaré d'ailleurs dans
son discours pour la première fois un
président élu ne va pas n'arrive pas à
avoir de majorité aux législatives
mais tout ça avec un ton un peu
déçu comme en asie mais il est allé un
petit peu vite en besogne non je dis je
crois que la raison mitterrand 88 n'a
qu'une majorité relative mais c'est tout
de même une majorité là je crois que
pour jean luc mélenchon aussi l'enjeu
c'était de rappeler le programme and do
they do in on arrêterait
et c'est amusant s'il a assez il t'aime
bon en communication au delà du ton et
un convoi et sur l'économie la ses
forces seraient que les françaises sont
pas forcément des stars en économie mais
quand même envie de comprendre et de
wimbledon il ya des punchline assez
simples souvent très fausse elle sera
une histoire des 80 milliards de budget
en fait c'est des ratios donc ces
deux-là déficit sur sur croissance donc
c'est pas 80 gares en soit ça dépend du
ça dépend les objectifs que donne à
bruxelles tout dépend comment la
croissance évolué comment le déficit
évolue donc c'est n'importe quoi de
donner un chiffre absolu comme c'est en
milliards mais il est assez bon parce
qu'il sort des chiffres comme ça qui
donne l'impression qu'on comprend des
trucs un peu obscur et en vagues qui
vont partir le débat dans des vraiment
dans le fossé mais mais ils allaient que
mal je trouve assez fort sur l'économie
voilà c'est ces fausses qui dit mais des
fosses à une beaucoup de galères très
convaincu et je pense qu'il convainc
beaucoup de monde parce que et on manque
un peu de culture économique dans le
pays et la façon qu'il a d'expliquer
c'est que ces mécanismes
oui valence est apprécié parce que c'est
faux un point sur quatre au delà de
l'économie sur la de politique
électorale pur aussi je n'ai pas entendu
jorick mélenchon ni marine le pen aurait
donné des consignes de vote claires
alors il semblerait que marine le pen
demande d'avec les électeurs
s'abstiennent enfin lorsque il y à un
duel entre la nuit passe et ensemble ce
que jordan bardella a confirmé
d'ailleurs sur tf1 il a déclaré qu'il
voterait blanc dans le cas d'un scénario
second tour du ps majorité et il estime
que ses électeurs feront pareil votre
blanc alors ou abstention mais jean-luc
mélenchon n'a formulé aucune consigne de
vote de vote me semble utile sau si j'ai
loupé quelque chose alors après dans la
majeure partie des cas c'est vrai que
c'est lui qui sera concernée est
finalement sorti le reste soit 107
circonscriptions où la nuit mais ce ne
serait pas présente reste que c'est
étonnant de ne pas donner de consigne de
vote dans les autres configurations de
la même façon il sera intéressant de
voir s'il y a des consignes de votes de
la part de la majorité sortante en cas
de second tour rassemblement national ni
grèce qu' est-ce que le pen et mélenchon
c'est blanc bonnet bonnet blanc ou bien
est-ce que
il y en a qu'on considère avec sa
majorité que y'en a un qui est
préférable au moins détestable que
l'autre alors d'après des confrères qui
sent sur twitter je suis et qui savent
ce qui se passe en ce moment à l'elysée
lacroix aurait dit
donc s'il serait une fois confirmée dans
ce sera compliqué qu'il prenne parti
national qui avait quand même dans le si
on peut parler de diabolisation en avait
un qui était quand même un peu plus de
diaboliser que l'autre c'était le
rassemblement national ce serait donc un
retour un peu dans quelque sorte un
remake mais dérivé du ni-ni sarkozien
c'est tout ce qui reste apparemment tu
sarkozy
la soutient a soutient emmanuel macron
ce qu'on peut lire dans le figaro
magazine avec l'interview exclusive
qu'il a accordée à charles jaigu
c'est définitif un jean michel blanquer
air donc jean-michel blanquer représenté
dans le loiret qui serait éliminé un
commentaire peut être sûr sur ça
guillaume vous qui avez consacré
justement votre édito dans le figaro
magazine à l'éducation
d'abord ça c'est un point de vue
personnel je trouve que c'est assez
injuste parce que parce que tel homme
qui a essayé de réformer l'éducation
nationale avec un bonheur inégal mais on
sait bien que c'est difficile de faire
bouger de mammouth
ça montre aussi que c'est pas une
position facile d'être dans la majorité
quand on a débarqué du gouvernement
parce que on pouvait considérer que
c'était une forme de désaveu blanca ne
soit pas maintenu et puis troisième
chose d'un malheureusement judith
waintraub l'a écrit là encore dans le
dernier film avec celui de ce week end
la majorité des manuels macro est de
moins en moins clair sur sa position
vis-à-vis des problèmes de laïcité sur
les dangers communautariste et main l'un
de ceux qui dans la majorité incarné
cette ligne laïque et républicaine
c'était jean-michel blanquer de toute
évidence ça lui a pas réussi d'ailleurs
2 deux personnes sur cette ligne là ont
été investis par la république en marche
notamment la version était puisqu'au
congrue pour le printemps le public oui
en fait il ya eu
vraiment du printemps république à une
seule personne qui ait marqué le bret
qui est l'ancien drh de charlie hebdo
qui a été officiellement investie mais
sinon
la république en voir son avatar
semble en sort merci et je vis à devoir
me mettre dans la caisse pour les cinq
prochaines années si ça dure tant
en revanche ensemble donc investi
l'ancienne présidente du cran le conseil
représentatif des associations noires de
france qu'est un truc ouvertement
vertement rassis raciale
revendiquant une approche par as
est-ce que les socialistes seraient
prêts à n'a appliqué le programme
économique de jean luc mélenchon cas de
délits soit mon à toute façon c'est ce
soir il n'y aura pas de victoire donc la
question en effet après c'est dans
quelle mesure le groupe va rester unie à
l'assemblée il ya de telles différences
au départ de vision notamment sur
l'économie l'europe c'est incroyable que
le parti socialiste ait accepté ce
programme qui va qui ferait à court
terme exploser la zone euro
donc c'est qu'il ya une très grande
probabilité que très rapidement surtout
à l'ipsi gagnait bombe à tout le monde
se laisse embarquer le live ils vont
avec la première force d'opposition mais
malgré tout ne vont pas gagner que très
rapidement chacun reprenne ses petits et
qui est différents groupes dont on va
voir ça ce matin des sujets d'assemblée
dans les prochains les prochains mois
et c'est vrai qu'il est possible aussi
que ensemble cherche des appuis aussi
auprès de socialisme il faut voir aussi
que la prochaine élection c'est
finalement bientôt les prochaines
élections en 2024 les européennes c'est
là qu'il sera intéressant de voir ce que
ce qu'il advient de cette alliance pour
cette élection parce que enfin
précisément c'est aux européennes on va
avoir des partis politiques qui vont
être sur des lignes diamétralement
opposés parce qu'entre les socialistes
les verts et
france 1 soumise à propos de l'europe je
vois pas très bien comment cette fois ci
ils vont pouvoir y aller avec un
programme commun qui serait crédible
pour les électeurs autant que sauf
erreur de ma part il n'est pas prévu de
groupe parlementaire unique dans
l'accord chaque heure hommage aux
concessionnaires
et chacun aura son groupe mais cela dit
moi je crois qu'à une fois que la
couleuvre est avalée c'est très
difficile
de revenir en arrière
il ya quand même malgré toutes les
incohérences que vous soulignez toutes
les deux à juste titre notamment sur sur
l'europe il ya depuis des années une
progression au sein même du ps de
secours anti européen et sur
la laïcité
la garantie républicaine le mot est un
peu fort mais en tout cas pour une
laïcité accommodante une laïcité
adjectiv et en témoigne la victoire de
benoît hamon
lors des en 2017
lors de la primaire contre manuel valls
et la défaite cinglante de manuel valls
à gauche cette alliance correspond à une
évolution
de l'électorat claudius 15 dans le chat
qui réagit à notre plateau depuis depuis
l'annoncé des premiers résultats et
qu'il nous dit à vous entendre on
croirait on pourrait croire que
mélenchon n'a pas remporté de victoire
ce soir qu'est ce que vous lui répondez
à claudius car qu'est-ce que vous la
jouer les riches ont réussi son pari il
voulait être ministre non pour être
ministre il faut avoir la majorité à
l'assemblée nationale
ce ne sont que des projections ce que
nous avons à notre disposition mais il
semblerait que la majorité macro nist
est à peu près 100 députés davance est
encore là ce sont nos estimations les
plus les plus prudentes sur
sur jean luc mélenchon et la nuque donc
effectivement si son pari c'était celui
là alors c'est un échec si son pari
c'était de le remettre en selle pour
2027 alors là pour le coup peut-être que
c'est plus réussis on a tous souligné à
quel point marine le pen était peu
audible cela dit soit vous la faire de
politique fiction aux dernières
législatives je crois qu'il y avait huit
ou neuf députés du rassemblement
national n'a pas empêché marine le pen
d'être au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle et 2022 donc la halle à
l'assemblée nationale n'est pas le
l'antichambre de de l'élection
présidentielle et vous y croyez vous
jean luc mélenchon qui se présenteraient
encore en 2027 pas dit qu'il arrêtait
c'est très difficile
et oui en ce moment là on sent pas une
furieuse envie de disparaître de la
scène si intéressant c'est que il a
comme 17 référence absolue de la science
politique et de groupe abba le wydad
t'excite hall donc donc avec son score à
la présidentielle il a réussi à à
vraiment faire une opa sur le parti
socialiste europe écologie les verts est
à mon avis c'est un c'est un atout
maître qui va continuer à pouvoir
exploiter dans dans la vie politique
nationale sauf évidemment si choisi de
se retirer mais c'est pas forcément son
tempérament à mon avis devant cet
hommage absolument sublime au groupe
abba et
rock suédois
nathalie nous dit l'enjeu du second tour
sera de priver la macro ni d'une
majorité parlementaire ce qui réduira
son pouvoir de nuisance à l'heure où on
se parle vu les premières projections
qu'on a qui ne sont jamais bien compris
céline que des projections la rd 6 202
la fouille est aussi dans tous les cas
ça reste un enjeu bien sûr que ça reste
un enjeu parce que pour la pour la messe
je feins majorité actuelle l'enjeu c'est
essayez d'obtenir une majorité absolue
avec ses alliés et si possible sans ses
alliés puisque pour gouverner il faudra
s'appuyer s'il n'a pas la majorité si le
reconquête pardon reconquête pas du tout
reconquête renaissance
c'est vrai que c'est compris si
renaissance à une n'a pas la majorité
absolue seul il va pouvoir il va devoir
s'appuyer sur le modèle et horizons qui
peut tout à fait avoir des velléités
différentes faire entendre des
discordances c'est donc c'est il ya
vraiment un enjeu quand même dans cet
entre deux tours pour le parti des
manuels macron
le parti donc des malades macron qui
arriverait deuxième selon les
estimations qu'on va revoir dans un
instant qu'ils les dernières estimations
que le cas de l'ifop et voilà qui
apparaît c'est magique 25 6% alors c'est
en tête dans notre classement mais sait
il arriverait donc deuxièmes derrière la
nuque baisse
26,1 pour cent est l'une des premières
infos de la soirée c'est que une des
figures de proue de la majorité l'ancien
ministre jean michel blanquer seraient
éliminés dans le loiret dès le premier
tour elisabeth bornes également doit
s'exprimer
elle est
bien cette prime et d'une minute à
l'autre et elle n'est pas éliminé
puisque selon les premiers à
l'otage favorable dans la 4e
circonscription du calvados avec un peu
plus de 35%
6% et 6 à 36 pour 46% donc voilà
donc on attend
la déclaration de la première ministre
bien sûr qu'on vous diffusera en direct
une autre réaction peut-être c'est sûr
sur eric zemmour est ce que avec ce
score là il peut quand même espérer lui
d'être élu et
guillaume pelletier qui étaient les
scores dans l'or dans les
circonscriptions dont vous parlez donc
je peux pas m gallas est sûr d'une
estimation partielle à partir de 71 %
des suffrages ou là il était troisième
mine par et puis d'autre part surtout il
ne passait pas le seuil fatidique des 12
5% des inscrits il était à 10 le pam est
la leçon qu'il ne pouvait pas se bâtir
donc il ne pouvait pas être élu
effectivement si
j'ai pas vu deux estimations en tous les
cas c'est effectivement c'est celle et
les premières informations qui remontent
au qu'eric zemmour qui serait éliminé
dès le premier tour on va continuer à
suivre également les nouvelles
déclarations dans quelques minutes sur
le plan économique
pour l'instant ce serait quand même
là
s'ils annulent pèse quand même bien ce
score là et même si jean luc mélenchon
ne sera pas premier ministre hun sen fou
etc
je viens de lire que guillaume pelletier
est éliminé donc il est arrivé 5e
[Musique]
des députés souvent d'eux dans la sphère
d'ailleurs lors de les électeurs
en tous les cas dans sa circonscription
conception dans le dans le loir et cher
vous pouvez voir d'ailleurs grâce à
l'excellent travail
des équipes du figaro date à être
jean-luc dont jean pierre brunet le
directeur technique des nouveaux médias
au figaro les résultats dans plusieurs
circonscriptions vous aurez les
qualifiés des 577 circonscriptions qui
vont paraître toute la soirée dans tous
les cas selon les résultats sont les
chiffres du ministère de l'intérieur qui
risque d'être également ajustés au moins
à la marge on nous dit qu est d avoir
la primeur c'est faire vivre notre
démocratie à titre personnel enfin je
veux remercier les habitants de la 6e
circonscription du calvados de m'avoir
pressé en tête de ce premier tour
aujourd'hui plus d'un français sur deux
ne s'est pas rendu aux urnes et cela
personne ne peut s'y résoudre notre
premier devoir collectif c'est de faire
reculer l'abstention nous continuerons
d'y oeuvrer en réformant nos
institutions et en modernisant le
dialogue avec toute la société et avec
le gouvernement avec toute la majorité
je veux continuer à agir et apporter des
réponses concrètes aux difficultés des
français et préparer notre avenir
à toutes celles et ceux qui se sont
abstenus je veux dire ce soir de croire
dans la force de leur vote et de faire
entendre leur voix dimanche prochain
ce soir des millions de français ont
choisi les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle
grâce à eux et à notre présence massive
au second tour nous sommes la seule
force politique en mesure d'obtenir la
majorité à la semblait nationale nous
avons une semaine de mobilisation devant
nous une semaine pour convaincre une
semaine pour obtenir une majorité forte
et claire
seule cette majorité forte et claire
nous permettra de répondre aux urgences
qui pèsent sur le quotidien des français
et de relever les défis d'avenir
face à la situation du monde et à la
guerre aux portes de l'europe nous ne
pouvons pas prendre le risque de
l'instabilité et des approximations
face aux extrêmes nous seuls portons un
projet de cohérence de clarté et de
responsabilité
j'appelle donc toutes les forces
républicaine à se rassembler autour de
ce projet et de nos candidats
mesdames et messieurs dans une semaine
au delà des étiquettes ce sont nos
valeurs qui sont en jeu la liberté
l'égalité la fraternité et la laïcité
ce premier tour nous montre que ce
combat est toujours d'actualité et que
nous ne devons jamais cesser de défendre
ses valeurs
car oui comme cela ne s'était jamais
produit dans l'histoire politique de
notre pays nous avons face à nous une
confusion inédite aux extrêmes face aux
extrêmes nous ne céderons rien ni d'un
côté ni de l'autre
ne céderons rien pour défendre le
progrès social la souveraineté de notre
pays et la république
car rappelons le le progrès social ça
n'est pas la décroissance économique
mais la liberté d'entreprendre et
d'innover pour créer plus d'emplois et
financer notre modèle social
le progrès social ça n'est pas une
écologie d'interdits et de taxes mais
une transition écologique ambitieuse qui
ne laisse personne au bord de la route
la souveraineté nationale ça n'est pas
la rupture avec l'europe la fascination
pour les régimes autoritaires et
l'alignement sur la russie mais bien une
nation forte au sein d'une europe plus
indépendante
la république ça n'est pas la remise en
cause nos institutions elle insulte
contre nous forces de l'ordre la
république ça n'est pas monter les
français les uns contre les autres en
les opposant selon leur religion leur
origine ou leur situation sociale mais
bien la laïcité et l'égalité entre tous
les citoyens
mes chers compatriotes
pour agir pour mettre en oeuvre les
engagements portés par le président de
la république nous avons besoin d'une
majorité forte et engagée
alors durant les jours qui viennent
comme moi toutes les candidates et tous
les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle
continuerons ensemble apporter avec
détermination notre projet celui du
pouvoir d'achat celui d'une grande
nation écologique celui du plein emploi
et du refus des inégalités de destin
dimanche prochain face aux extrêmes en
votant pour les candidats de la majorité
présidentielle vous permettrait à la
france d'être au rendez vous de son
avenir et de ses valeurs vive la
république et vive la france
voilà vous venez d'entendre la première
ministre elisabeth bornes qui donc
arrivé en tête de sa circonscription
dans le calvados et qui appelle grosso
modo à un ni ni pour le second tour à
faire bloc face aux extrêmes une
réaction peut-être and we mal joue sans
particulièrement d'ailleurs des landes
de voir la partition classique de
l'hyper centre la raison et à lörrach
tort de s'en priver elle le voit le
rappel l'écran les grandes lignes du
programme attaque la droite un autre à
gauche c'est un peu
ça manque un peu importe ça manque un
peu d'entrain on disait que c'était une
élection que ça se passait pas si mal
pour eux j'aurais attendu un ton un peu
plus voilà un peu plus confiants mais
bon je pense qu'il est dans la gravité
attention aux extrêmes et à la tension
et la somme est répartie sur
l'abstention je dit oui c'est pas la
première fois que
jean luc mélenchon et marine le pen que
le rassemblement national et la france
est soumise l'anus en l'occurrence sont
renvoyées dos-à-dos aussi nettement et
sans le moindre connu que disent ils en
général on reconnaît à l'extrême gauche
d'avoir des intentions louables même si
la
réalisation laisse à désirer là vraiment
la symétrie est parfait ça correspond
tout à fait à ce que les confrères
disait qu emmanuel macron avait déclaré
au cours de cette réunion qui est en
train de c'est à dire de sa majorité
on n'est pas du tout
dans on a faim on est parent donc
complètement dans le ni ni et on n'est
pas parce que le paradoxe pardon de
l'orientation des vénètes macron c'est
que tout en renvoyant dos à dos à dos
extrême gauche et extrême droite il
envoie des signes à l'est littoral jean
luc mélenchon c'est peut-être pour ça
que c'est un peu plus difficile à
traduire quand il dit sur les retraites
que la dernière version c'est bien sûr
on la fera cette réforme mais la
précédente étaient 65 ans au pouvoir il
ya peut-être moyen de moyenner ça se
discute donc taper très très fort sur
georges luc mélenchon ne l'empêchent pas
de faire des concessions sur le fonds a
sonné victor
guillaume
puisqu'on parle de réunion à l'elysée il
ya d'autres informations apparemment
passion mais ça reste à vraiment à
confirmer on n'envisage rey à l'elysée
un déplacement des manuels maquereau en
ukraine entre les deux tours mais encore
une fois c'est une c'est une piste donc
je ne tenais pas l'indicatif un mot
peut-être sur les interventions des
abbesses banque c'est là qu'on voit le
la performance quand même du maquereau
ni parce que cette femme était presque
inconnu des français il ya quelques
semaines elle va probablement être la
patronne de la majorité le président la
république a été réélue et malgré une
campagne extrêmement dynamique me départ
jean luc mélenchon leleu la majorité est
plutôt solide donc eu l'intuition de
départ du maquereau nive c'est à dire
entre moi n'existe rem il n'y a plus
rien elle se confirme encore ce soir
semble-t-il enfin c'est vrai qu'avant
même l'idée de la consigne de vote y ait
l'idée de d'obtenir ce qu'elle appelle
une majorité forte engagée ça va
vraiment être la gageure de cette
premier ministre est de réussir à entrer
dans ce rôle de chef de la majorité que
pour le moment elle est là un petit peu
quand même du mal à occuper même si elle
a fait pas mal de déplacements en plus
des déplacements dans sa circonscription
en normandie est donc là ça va vraiment
être le rôle qui va lui être imparti et
il va falloir qu'elle y aille forte
puisqu'il va il ya un enjeu réel pour
obtenir la majorité absolue et c'est pas
du tout gagné d'avancé ouais on peut
dire plus que c'est emmanuel macron l'a
choisie elle c'est pas pour ses qualités
de charisme et de leadership
messi lui s'il se voir même de la
majorité dont pendant l'entre-deux-tours
c'est vrai qu'il va falloir qu'elles
l'occupent ce rôle là merci beaucoup
merci avocate d'avoir été avec nous
d'avoir suivi en direct les résultats du
premier tour des législatives
à bientôt peut-être de voir le bar est
effectivement vous attend pour le pour
le deuxième tour la semaine prochaine et
merci beaucoup de nous avoir suivi la
soirée électorale
continue on va faire le point sur les
commentaires les déclarations et avec
daphné caravaca oui merci vincent alors
à gauche les réactions ne se sont pas
fait attendre
jean luc mélenchon a entamé sa prise de
parole sur un ton c'est juste très
solennelle en disant que la vérité est
que les le parti présidentiel est battu
au premier tour et des faits le député
sortant des bouches du rhône a ajouté
qu'il appelait le peuple a déferlé au
second tour puis alexis corbière sur bfm
s'adressant à clément bonne a estimé que
ce soir l'événement c'est que vous êtes
derrière du côté de la majorité
présidentielle hélas elisabeth bornes
remercie personnellement les habitants
de la sirc 6e circonscription du
calvados qu'ils l'ont placé en tête
olivia grégoire porte-parole du
gouvernement a déclaré sur france 2 on
est content de voir que la majorité est
présente dans une écrasante majorité de
circonscription maintenant à droite les
élèves ne sont pas morts c'est ce qu'a
déclaré rachida dati sur tf1 et enfin
marine le pen a remercié ses électeurs
qui l'ont placé à 55% des voix la
candidate du rassemblement national
appelle ses électeurs à ne pas choisir
entre les deux coalitions en tête elle a
profité de cette prise de parole pour
encourager ses électeurs à confirmer ce
bon score je cite tueur fonds
d'abstentionnisme
daphné on va accueillir d'un instant à
l'autre nos nouveaux plateaux nos
nouveaux invités effectivement voit
arriver emmanuel rivière directeur
international de des études politiques
chez kantar bonsoir emmanuel
peut-être une première réaction c'est le
mini généraliser ce soir
le ni-ni et puis le et est en fait le
nid victoire claire pour la
baisse malgré tout peut-être une
solution en tête ce sera bien guéri plus
importante après tout va se jouer dans
l'entre-deux-tours ni réussite pour les
candidats d'ensemble et candidat de la
majorité présidentielle
c'est la principale leçon de la soirée
mais tout dépend comment s'additionner
et parce que voilà cet entre deux tours
il va probablement voir s'affronter dans
les campagnes dans une campagne 1 2l
typique qui sera celui de la république
en marge d'un ensemble contre un
candidat de l'ani baisse ce qui est en
nous une étape supplémentaire de
reconfiguration du paysage politique où
ben les
électeurs des candidats défaits parmi
eux notamment les électeurs républicains
selector rassemblement national de vont
se demander comment ils arbitrent ce
match là ce sera pas le seul duel bien
entendu et je trouve que l'un des
enseignements de cette soirée c'est le
score du rassemblement national le
meilleur score du rassemblement national
des élections législatives une
réplication quasi à l'identique du score
de la présidentielle c'est absolument
unique pour ce parti qui avait
l'habitude de faire de bien meilleures
performances à la présidentielle que
dans l'initiative y compris
immédiatement mais pour autant dans les
projections convoi et sont même pas sûrs
d'avoir un groupe à l'assemblée oui
parce que là pour le coup c'est une
caractéristique qui perdure du
rassemblement national qui s'est vu
d'ailleurs au second tour de la
présidentielle
c'est un parti qui continue à faire
plutôt à créer des blocs contre lui et
donc de même que marine le pen s'est vu
devancé par une très large majorité
autour d'emmanuel vaqueront avec le
ralliement
deux lecteurs qui n'aimait pas emmanuel
macron mais qui émet encore - marine le
pen pour les mêmes raisons c'est
toujours plus difficile pour les
candidats du rassemblement national de
franchir la barre des 2 la barre des 50%
mais il peut y avoir des regrets
peut-être du côté du rassemblement
national et de marine le pen contenu de
ce score ne va avoir pas été plus
ambitieux et plus ambitieuses au
lendemain du premier tour et d'avoir
laisser à d'autres le soin de créer des
alliances il ya aussi des voix qui sont
perdus et les voix de deux voilà les
voix de reconquête qui ont sans doute
enlevé une partie des voix dans
certaines circonscriptions pas partout
et peut-être dans le sud est or ont
privé les candidats du rassemblement
national de quelques voix qu aurait été
utile potentiellement pour se maintenir
alors ça ce sont des données qui vont
être commentée qu'on va demander on va
dont on va demander le commentaire et
guillaume bernard bonsoir
maître de conférences de l'iss à la
roche sur yon politologue et auteur de
l'indispensable la guerre à droite aura
bien lieu on peut même le maître ou
passé au présent et sans doute à
l'avenir oui on va voir ça avec vous
pour cette nouvelle tranche de deux
heures sur le
président doxa et véronique résulte
présidente de bakbone consulting au doxa
bakbone consulting qui publie chaque
semaine un sondage pour le figaro le
dernier portait sur l'abstention d'abord
avant peut-être de revenir avec chacun
d'entre vous sur
sur les sur ces élections plus en détail
peut être un premier commentaire une
réaction sur sur les résultats revient
d'avoir celle d'emmanuel gaël
c'est pas une surprise c'est une
catastrophe des nôtres démocratique
alors parle pas des résultats détaillés
des autres mais du chiffre de
l'abstention il était attendu il était
prévu et on est comparable à 2010 m mais
si on peut se satisfaire d'avoir plus
d'un électeur sur deux qui s'abstient à
des élections
bah ça dépend j'étais en route pour
venir ici donc je sais pas si les
chiffres ont changé mais moi j'avais des
chiffres à 53% sur peut-être d'autres
gens en deux ans 53 destinations à 51 5%
de ouais on verra mais de toute façon 51
52 53 ça veut dire qu'une majorité
d'électeurs se sont abstenus a su alors
même alors même qu'on avait eu un enjeu
il s'agissait d'une élection à fort
enjeu elle était annoncée depuis
longtemps avec la poussée de la nuque
baisse avec la perspective ce
qu'expliquait jean luc mélenchon d'avoir
une cohabitation mélenchon premier
ministre une des forces politiques enfin
un climat politique qui aurait pu être
jugée plus intéressant que l'élection de
validation de 2017 et pourtant
l'abstention est encore là à ses
premiers constats et puis le deuxième
constat c'est l'incertitude dans
laquelle nous sommes il ya des
projections en sièges qui circulent il
faut prendre ça avec prudence on n'est
qu'un premier tour pour le moment et
l'incertitude dans laquelle nous sommes
c'est est ce qu'on se dirige vers une
majorité qui pourrait encore être
absolue pour emmanuel macron et ses
alliés c'est possible ou est-ce qu'on se
dirige vers une chambre introuvable qui
nécessiterait soit des alliances avec l
air le perdant gagnant de cette élection
le mouvement qui aurait réalisé des
scores les moins favorables qui aurait
connu les baisses les plus fortes et qui
finalement deviendrait le finalement
larbitre le juge de paix de l'élection
ou est-ce qu'il suffirait à emmanuel
macron de récupérer cinq ou six députés
pour voir la majorité à l'assemblée et
dans ce cas là eh bien il s'en sortira
pas ce qu'il trouvera toujours deux ou
trois députés dissidents de gauche ou de
droite pour venir leurs alliés donc
c'est ça l'enjeu de ce soir
moi ce qui m'a frappé c'est que peu de
participation peu de discussions avant
appelez-vous on s'est vu toutes les
semaines et on peut pas dire que les
français étaient passionnés sur les
réseaux c'est moins qu'on puisse dire
même certains ne savais même pas qu'on
votait ce week end comme ça est-ce qui
est pas de se déplacer
ça me frappe encore ce soir parce qu'il
ya quand même très peu de messages
rapport à un événement quand même
nationales et locales et après on voit
quand même pendant la campagne ce qui
s'exprime beaucoup bien sûr sont élus
pèse qui invite d'ores et déjà à se
remobiliser pour la semaine prochaine
qui explique que bien sûr messieurs les
sondeurs vous allez mentir que bien sûr
messieurs les journalistes vous allez
tronquée et changer la réalité mais que
oui il est possible que monsieur
mélenchon arrive à matignon donc
mobilisons nous disons nous c'est le
maître mot ce soir et puis on a de
l'autre côté finalement peu de militants
qui sont très actifs et dans les
différents commentaires vous pouvez voir
par contre c'est beaucoup de gens plutôt
l air ou de droite qui ont peur et qui
se disent il va vraiment falloir se
mobiliser pour la semaine prochaine avec
une notion de vote utile donc en fait
globalement c'est pas tant une surprise
que ça mais juste la confirmation que ça
ne passionne pas et ce qui suit sont
soit très très content soir ont très
très peur il ya une dernière estimation
qui les donnent maintenant au coude à
coude celle ifop montrait fait ensemble
25,9 donc ça se resserre on va
d'ailleurs mettre à jour ses résultats
dans nos adorent nos infographies
guillaume un commentaire sur sa d'abord
sur l'abstention et sur ses résultats
convient de donner alors sur
l'abstention je crois qu'effectivement
il faut lourdement insisté sur le fait
que même si ça n'est pas un record même
si on
nakk un niveau d'abstention comparable à
celui de 2010 est c'est un très fort
taux d'abstention et c'est une
dégringolade entre la président de la
participation la présidentielle et les
législatives
or je vous rappelle que nous avons des
législatives qui interviennent deux mois
après la présidentielle c'est-à-dire un
laps de temps deux fois plus important
que d'habitude d'habitude on peut penser
que les électeurs des camps qui ont
perdu la présidentielle se démobilisent
énormément parce que ben voilà la
présidentielle puis les choix politiques
et donc on considère que à quelques
semaines après l'arrêt après l'élection
du président de la république il est
logique qu'ils aient majorité
parlementaire là
on a eu deux mois deux mois d'une
campagne extrêmement atone et
pourtant il n'ya pas véritablement eu de
remobilisation
des opposants emmanuel macron donc par
conséquent c'est vrai que c'est une
claque pour la place politique c'est à
dire que il y à un désintérêt il y à une
défiance vis-à-vis des partis politiques
qui est somme toute importante et qu'il
faut quand même relevé la deuxième chose
vous m'interrogez comme tout le monde
sur les résultats
je crois qu'on l'a tous plus ou moins
dit à un moment ou un autre
commenter les résultats au niveau
national d'une de
577 élections au niveau local et au soir
du premier tour c'est à dire tant que
les cheveux les jeux ne sont pas
totalement fait c'est extrêmement
difficile une indication sur les
rapports de force oui mais quand vous
avez que la moitié des électeurs qui y
vont
ça veut dire que vos rapports de force
en termes de nombre de voix réelle on
tourne en termes de suffrages exprimés
réellement par rapport à la
présidentielle
c'est extrêmement peu c'est à dire que
même quelqu'un qui aurait augmenté ses
résultats par exemple
mélenchon a fait 22 et demi à la
présidentielle son alliance électorale
fait ce soir 26 % mais avec le taux de
participation en berne par rapport à la
présidentielle en nombre de voix c'est
beaucoup moins importante donc ce sont
allés les rapports de force ils seront
je crois
véritablement significatif au soir du
second tour lorsque l'on aura vu déjà
dans les heures qui viennent et dans les
jours qui viennent quelles vont être
véritablement les duels est-ce qu'on va
avoir des duels
nuxe et rennes nuxe heller mlr om et
rennes etc ça ça va être vraiment
intéressant et ensuite on verra bien au
soir du second tour quels sont les
reports de voix qui se seront fait
effectivement ça a été évoqué il est
vraisemblable que des électeurs aient
l'air vont
lorsque leur candidat a été éliminé bien
se reporter vers l om partner par peur
de lannux alors ça c'est visiblement pj
alors vous allez nous le confirmer pj
mais doit être un électeur à l'air et
10,6 et nu pèse face à mâcon dans ma
circonscription je préfère encore voter
pour le candidat ma chronique
une question peut-être gaël
a priori la majorité des duels vont être
des duels lrm une épaisse oui oui de
même que la majorité des duels il ya
cinq ans étaient les duels lrm les l'air
ce qui d'ailleurs va accompagner le
changement de contenu et la
reconfiguration du paysage politique
pour produire ce que disait guillaume
est quand même une leçon qu'on peut
tirer il me semble ce sport on est en
train d'apprendre en fait ce que c'est
une initiative qui suit non pas une
élection d'un président public mais une
réélection sans avoir perdu le pouvoir
dans le cas d'une cohabitation c'est à
dire une élection législative dans le
prolongement d'un mandat et c'était tout
à fait frappant dans le baromètre le
sacro-saint baromètre du figaro magazine
baromètre politique réalisé par compteur
on le réalise est par contre de l'été
epoca église warg avait absolument aucun
effet dans la confiance des manuels
macron ni de sa réélection ni de la
nomination de son gouvernement il
partait plutôt du terrain et c'est pas
effectivement s'il y aura une majorité à
l'assemblée nationale dimanche soir
prochain mais s'il y en a une mais ce
sera la première fois qu'une majorité
sera issu des urnes alors que caen qui
prétend réunir une majorité et moins de
30% au premier tour une majorité
d'habitude c'est issu de 40% la dernière
fois c'est une exception 32% pour les
ravalements premier tour là autour de 25
26% et bien et non une difficulté
supplémentaire dont ce sera pas en tout
cas le même quinquennat c'est sûr que le
quinquennat 2017 2022
il ya une quatrième tayenne
circonscription kong était évidemment
c'est la circonscription du de celui qui
remplace
jean luc mélenchon dans les bouches du
rhône la 4e circonscription donc il ya
une une projection qui a annoncé
évidemment monsieur bompard en tête à 52
9% des voix mais il ya encore une fois
une énorme abstention aussi c'est à
souligner dans cette circonscription et
64% la projection tout cas qui se
conclura au deuxième tour alors comme
pour lyon comme monaco les peines ne
sont pas des circonscriptions gagner du
premier coup un point important je crois
que
sincèrement sont sans aucune je dirais
aussi lité vis-à-vis de jean-luc
mélenchon et de la nuque il est quand
même peu vraisemblable que celui ci
obtienne une majorité de députés dont
289 députés en revanche qui est
évidemment l'enjeu c'est la question de
savoir est ce que emmanuel macron aura à
lui seule une majorité parlementaire et
il aura besoin de supplétifs
quelques socialistes
ou quelques ou quelques l air plus
vraisemblablement pour colmater pour
colmater les brèches ça ça sera est
important parce que jusqu'à présent mine
de rien on a toujours eu le phénomène
majoritaire c'est à dire qu'ils ont
président nouvellement élu obtenait une
majorité parlementaire à sa botte ça
serait la première fois effectivement
qu'il ne l'obtiendrait pas parce que je
vous rappelle quand on a eu des
cohabitations c'est lorsque les
législatives intervenues sommités au
minimum deux ans ou quatre ans après
l'élection présidentielle soit
mitterrand en 1988 il n'a pas une
majorité relative et une majorité
relative cesser admettons mais alors que
le mets mais enfin tout de même il
obtient une majorité il obtient quand
même une majorité les oppositions ne
sont pas capables de gouverner ensemble
une remarque de cet internaute qui nous
dit que le système à deux tours
l'absence de proportionnelle le fait que
les législatives sont juste après les
présidentielles constituent trois
explications majeures de cette
abstention oui un combat long et une
abstention structurelles profondes on
l'a mesuré dans notre sondage avec vous
avec le figaro avec backbone consulting
sur les fondements les ressorts de
l'abstention une abstention préoccupante
parce qu'elle correspond à des raisons
plus structurelles que conjoncturelles
mais il ya aussi un phénomène qui est
lié à cesser à ce scrutin je rappelle
qu'à peu près tous les présidents sinon
tous depuis une trentaine d'années ont
juré craché par terre surtout promis de
toutes les manières qu'ils
introduiraient de la proportionnelle
parce que c'est complètement
incompréhensible un système dans lequel
le pouvoir le pouvoir réel ou procèdent
de l'assemblée donc et du gouvernement
qui en découle est que ce pouvoir
finalement soit ne représente absolument
pas d des pans entiers de l'électorat
c'est un vrai sujet emmanuel macron
l'avait promis en il ne l'a pas fait ses
prédécesseurs n'avait pas fait mieux là
il va vraiment falloir résoudre ce
problème parce que imaginez un peu avec
les scores qu'on a ce soir on pourrait
très bien être dans des configurations
sait pas ce qui nous arrive mais où la
nuque baisse pourrait se retrouver avec
finalement 30 députés ou 40 députés
c'est ce qu'a vécu le front national est
ce que vivra encore d'une certaine
manière le rassemblement national ce
soir avec des scores qui représente
normalement un électeur sur cinq et qui
finalement était déjà la présidentielle
en plus et qui finalement se retrouvera
avec la portion congrue à l'assemblée
nationale donc ça c'est un vrai sujet
qui pourra peut-être gros problème
démocratique si vous combinez ça plus
une abstention massive le souci de la
représentativité de nos dirigeants va se
poser mais le même
l'abstention massive elle vient aussi de
ça parce que quand on regarde les gros
avantage surtout sur le rassemblement
national on a beaucoup fait y avait
beaucoup de commentaires j'ai entamé de
façon je vais pas bougé je peux aller
voter parce qu'on ne sera pas et c'était
dans nos balcons alors ça dépend des
circonscriptions sacs et des
mobilisations différenciées en fonction
des circonscriptions là où le candidat
et rennes étaient en capacité d'arriver
en tête de gagner là il va y avoir une
mobilisation de l'électorat en revanche
dans l'ouest
c'est en fait il n'y croit pas nous qui
se disent pourquoi est-ce que je vais me
déplacer et ils ont bien raison c'est à
dire qu'ils n'ont pas de raison de se
déplacer parce qu'ils ont la balle assez
compliqué et je lisais aussi ce soir des
tas de gens qui ne comprenaient pas
donc on annonce 25-25 je vais regarder
projectionniste mais gérard c'est donc
vous êtes obligé ya des choix qui
arrivent et qui expliquent non mais
semaine proportionnelle c'est en fait c
est ce qu on appelle ça le compréhensive
est un combat moi j'aurai des
propositions que je sais que je suis
tout seul mais michel debré et moi
étions favorables à ça c'est le mode de
scrutin majoritaire uninominal à un tour
parce que critique mais ça veut dire que
celui qui arrive en tête dans une
circonscription est élu et ça oblige les
forces politiques à se rassembler à
constituer des coalitions encore faut-il
évidemment que ces coalitions soit
capable de gouverner de gouverner
ensemble les coalitions pour voir
désigner un seul candidat par
circonscription c'est encore le système
britannique
grande bretagne ça qui plutôt à une
réduction du nombre de parties qu'à la
création de coalition mais ils n'ont
jamais eu à ma connaissance un système
politique aussi éclaté que le nôtre sont
contentés d'avoir un nombre limité de
ram et sada présente retenue quand même
absolument nous ça n'a pas empêché le
lay bourg de remplacer petit à petit le
parti libéral dans l'antre de guerre
mondiale donc ça veut dire que l'or il y
à des mouvements de fonds dans l'opinion
publique des nouvelles forces politiques
peuvent peuvent émerger voilà mais moi
je ne dirais pas pour favoriser que la
représentativité c'était aussi pour
favoriser la visibilité la compréhension
des différences entre ces différentes
forces politiques peu de compréhension
le sentiment que se déplacer n'a pas
forcément de sens et puis un autre
phénomène qui sort de plus en plus
souvent c'est que les gens ne
comprennent pas toujours la réalité du
rôle des députés n'ont pas ce qu'ils ont
à faire mais nous la fallait différentes
commissions c'est pas toujours très
claire les gens le fait qu' il ya eu
pendant quelques quelques mois voire
quelques années ces derniers temps on
expliquait que les députés godillots et
qui n'étaient là que pour appuyer sur
des boutons ça n'a pas aidé non plus à
mobiliser les gens sur un ensemble de
choses qui complique et le dernier point
est souvent qu'ils se disent qu'en fait
les hélices quelqu'un est passé plein de
choses pendant ces cinq années aura
parié puisque regard des cinq dernières
années c'était difficile d'imaginer
qu'on avait traversé une pandémie qu'on
allait avoir garé en ukraine et 10 mais
je ne sais pas je ne connais pas bien
mon député ce n'est plus la même
histoire qu'avant où les députés étaient
très ancrée et donc disent je ne sais
pas bien ce qu'ils pensent donc est ce
qu'il va faire face à l'inconnu qui est
devant donc là aussi ça ne mobilise pas
un canthare publique évoquant publie
cette semaine un sondage qui montre que
l' un tiers des interviewés connaissent
le nom de leur député de nova et 38 %
moins de quatre sur dix se rappelle d'un
moment important à l'assemblée nationale
au cours des cinq dernières années ce
qui veut dire qu'il ya au moins un
français sur 10 qui est allé voter
bravement ou législatives sans se
rappeler quoi que ce soit j'ai ce qu'il
s'est passé ou à l'assemblée nationale
au cours des cinq dernières années gail
simone juste une question pour un peu
clore le débat la sueur sur l'abstention
comment enfin comment elle a impacté
cette élection est ce qu'on sait à qui
elle a profité ou pas déjà alors un
petit peu
dans le sondage que nous avions réalisée
avant le scrutin évidemment avec gbagbo
en consulting et le figaro on avait
essayé de comprendre ce qu'elle serait
l'estimé et de voir qui elle allait
toucher et ce qu'est ce qu'étaient ces
ressorts vous venez d'évoquer les uns et
les autres différents ressorts le disais
tout à l'heure qui a vu des intérêts
structurelles quand même à si vous avez
un tiers des gens que nous je vais
m'abstenir ars de toute façon je ne
m'intéresse pas ou plus à la politique
en général et 20% qu'ils nous disent se
disait veronica l'instant c'est à dire
je pense qu'elle est votée ne change
rien à ma vie alors à ma situation ni à
celle de pays et puis il y avait une
proportion à peu près comparable les
gens qui disent toute façon mon candidat
n'a aucune chance dans cette
circonscription lane dans la
configuration actuelle donc je n'irai
pas ce qui est ce qui est troublant
quand même c'est la notion d' abstention
très différenciée sociologiquement et
générationnelle mans à la limite si on
raisonne comme de bon sauveur manuel et
moi on se congèle représentativité ou à
l'orgue et ans que vous êtes ce ne
serait pas très chaud permet en fêtant
un petit peu
en étant un petit peu
obsédé par nos chiffres on pourrait dire
si il y avait exactement la même
proportion d'abstentionnistes dans
toutes les couches de la population la
reprise le dirigeant serait issu d'un
choix représentatif là en l'occurrence
dans notre sondage on voyait que chez
les employés les ouvriers chez les
foyers on était à 64 %
d'abstentionnistes donc les deux tiers
alors que chez les cadres on n'était
qu'à un peu plus de 40% chez les foyers
modestes on est 20 points au dessus de
l'abstention chez les foyers aisés on
verra les sondages après si ça se
confirme est très étonnant qu'ils aient
des gros écarts et chez les jeunes alors
là c'est quand même un vrai sujet on est
quasiment aux deux tiers
d'abstentionnistes entre 63 et 64 % dans
les deux tranches d'âge de jeunes de 18
à 34 ans alors que les seniors votent à
plus de 60 de près de 60% ça signifie un
double risque de gérontocratie si on
pousse le bouchon un peu plus loin et
aussi de suffrage censitaire qui si l
option ou si on va encore un peu plus
loin dans le schéma avec finalement des
gens aisés urbains éduqués et disposant
de foyers de revenus élevés et âgés qui
votent pour un pays pour gouverner et
prendre effet décidé de loi qui vont
concerner pour beaucoup des gens jeunes
parce que ça va les impacts et la
prochaine année vieilli et en général
ces gens là dedans vous parler ils
votent pour la majorité pour mac os x
alors c'était votre question pardon mais
d'un mot on voyait quand même que la
poussée de la nuque baisse permettait de
faire résister les électorats 1
notamment au mélenchonistes par rapport
à ce que une abstention marque est
sociologiquement comme cela aurait dû
les toucher l'erc en gros parce que des
heures 34 ans 18 ans d'intense les
électeurs de deux du ps et demain de 2,2
de france jeunes filles un peu c'est
l'aspect politique c'est à dire que
comme il y avait une dynamique favorable
pour jean luc mélenchon il n'a pas pâti
autant que cela de cette abstention très
marquée dans les foyers modestes et chez
les jeunes
jeu guillaume
ce soir est ce que j'ai un certain
nombre de
commentaires sur le chat du figaro qui
disent qu'il ya un certain nombre de
personnes qui en train us 1
mélenchonistes et macron ils voteront
mâcon est ce que on assiste à la
droitisation encore de l air est m et
c'est un peu l'un verse de votre
mouvement dextrogyre parce que
généralement c'est celle finalement
c'est la vieille histoire de la vie
politique française le vieux drame de la
droite française est à droite ce qui est
loin à gauche exactement historiquement
parlant c'est très souvent ça peut être
résumée par part par cette formule
moi si vous voulez je je je pense qu'il
ne faut pas regarder les résultats
électoraux sur le court terme je sais
bien que effectivement en 2017 et en
2022 il ya eu incontestablement un
moment mélenchon il a réussi à émerger à
s'imposer il a réussi à faire cette
coalition pour les législatives
pour autant est-ce qu'on peut
raisonnablement croire que la nuque
baisse est capable de gouverner et est
ce qu'elle est
si elle est si elle arrivait au pouvoir
semble avoir rapidement des divisions
moi je le crois pas à ces terres je
pense que c'est un cartel électoral qui
certes est efficace parce qu'il donne de
l'espoir à toute une partie de
l'électorat parce qu'il je dirais e
forme je dirais une opposition
symbolique à emmanuel macron mais pour
autant je ne crois pas la pérennité de
cette force politique bon en revanche
qu'il y ait des réflexes presque de
l'assist qui conduisent effectivement à
ce que et bien toute une partie de
l'électorat tout simplement fasse un
choix en fonction d'une proximité
d'aller bien qu'on politique c'est pas
j'ai viré un choix philosophique absolue
le bien le mal le vrai le beau c'est ce
dont on est le moins éloigné ou ceux
dont on est le plus proche donc lier les
électeurs qui finalement tout en
adhérant pas nécessairement une force
politique font le choix de préférer
cette force politique là à une autre et
en l'occurrence macron à la nuque je
vois rien de très étonnant de très
étonnant tout de même ne laissera pas
faire justement ça va en créer en 2010
est finalement beaucoup d'électeurs
socialistes s'était représenté 7 est
reporté sur le candidat et les oem voyez
ça et ça avait contribué donc à la
victoire depuis cinq ans à la victoire
de la leyre eux-mêmes et à l'époque on
considérait les oem quand même partis de
centre-gauche est ce que c'est encore le
cas ce soir est finalement est-ce que ça
c'est un papa votre le mouvement que
vous avez tout niveau d'un droit travail
on ne sait si c'est alors le mouvement
dextrogyre si vous me laissez une
seconde à mon efron monde des glaces le
mouvement dextrogyre c'est le fait que
la pression idéologique devient plus par
la gauche comme c'était le cas depuis la
révolution française et qu'elle vient
par la droite ça ne veut pas payer donc
ça veut dire que les forces politiques
glisse de manière inverse ce qu'elle
avait fait auparavant ça veut dire par
exemple que michel a identifié la
réunification idéologique du libéralisme
libéralisme culturel qui était restée à
gauche libéralisme économique avec
bruxelles sur la droite ça ne veut pas
pour autant dire que tout d'un coup tout
l'électorat français est de droite et
l'île maurice barrès ou charles maurras
mme j'ai jamais dit ça évidemment
en revanche
la force politique qu'elle macro 10
c'est plus une force centrale par le
fait qu'elle est je dirais par son
positionnement sur le spectre politique
que par le fait qu'elle soit
nécessairement centriste elle peut être
sur certains points qualifiable de
gauche ou sur certains d'entre eux prend
qualifiable de droite voilà et justement
il ya le leader des républicains qui
était chez nos confrères de france 2 et
qui la déclare qu'il ne veut donner
aucune voix pour les extrêmes aussi lui
aussi il pratique le ni ni et il a dit
qu'il réunira un conseil stratégique
demain pour savoir si vous allez établir
une une consigne de vote claire pour
second tour ou non des républicains tout
cas bruno retailleau avait dit lui qui
n'en donnerai pas avoir à voir ce que
vont faire les électeurs aient l'air
demain emmanuel rivière vous vouliez
réagir à ce que disait louis base donc
sur la mise en perspective historique
soit intéressante les mises en
perspective géographique aussi on a
entendu il est borgne dire ce soir de
choses tel a dit en gros il ya un risque
d'absence de majorité donc de marasme
l'immobilisme et cetera il faut lutter
contre cela et puis elle a dit aussi en
gros il faut faire le choix de la
majorité présidentielle contre les
extrêmes sous-entendant en fait l'espace
politique en france ce serait la
majorité présidentielle où les extrêmes
c'est vrai que c'est long très présent
dans la rhétorique consistait d'abord
donc
concise et marine le pen comme la
représentante de l'extrême droite n'a
rien de nouveau et des décennies que le
rassemblement national le front national
sont placés là par prendre part de la
classe politique mais du coup à
considérer l'ensemble des parties de la
nuque aces commettant qualifiable comme
ont qualifié auparavant elle est fille
ce qui est pas neutre du tout parce que
si on regarde les grandes démocraties
européennes n a absolument aucune où la
majorité enfin celle qui nous ressemble
en tout cas considère qu'il ya que la
majorité et les extrêmes ce degré de
polarisation de la vie politique en fait
on observe en ce moment
états unis ce n'est pas non plus anodin
puisque une sorte de consensus national
qui faisait que les deux parties se
succédaient mais travailler beaucoup
ensemble qui complètement rompu et là
c'est ça que je trouve anodin c'est
d'avoir aujourd'hui une majorité qui se
prétend la seule force non extrémiste du
pays ce qui pose aussi la question du
positionnement des républicains et de
l'intégration ou pas d'ailleurs dans le
cadre de la majorité on va une trentaine
de circonscriptions
sensible de l'été suivi par timothée
d'hellemmes sont subissent ce soir par
timothée d'hellemmes qui vient de nous
rejoindre
qui sont les élus qui sont les battues
quelles sont les surprises mon char
timothée et will vincent effectivement
les dernières estimations du ministère
de l'intérieur qui nous parviennent au
compte gouttes on suit ça de près on
surveille les circonscriptions sensible
celle des ministres notamment et la
première d'entre elles elisabeth bornes
qui est en ballottage favorable dans
l'assiette dans la sixième
circonscription du calvados son score 32
79% d'après les dernières estimations
officielles celles du ministère de
l'intérieur elle affrontera donc le
candidat de la nuque ps nommé gauchard
lors du second tour dimanche prochain on
attend toujours les résultats de
plusieurs autres circonscriptions
ministériel si je puis dire celle du
ministre de l'intérieur notamment gérald
darmanin pas de chiffres officiels pour
l'instant ce qui le concerne même s'il
revendique sur son compte twitter avoir
recueilli près de 40% des suffrages
gérald darmanin qui serait donc qualifié
sans surprise pour le second tour à
noter que damien abad le nouveau
ministre des solidarités au centre de la
polémique de la nouvelle équipe
gouvernementale pour des accusations
d'agression sexuelle et de viol ayant
fait l'objet de deux plaintes classées
sans suite il arrive en tête dans la 5e
circonscription de l'ain avec 33 des
gueules 30 38 % des voix 33 38 % des
voix pour damien abad il affrontera la
candidate de la nuque mais ce flou rance
pisani qui elle a recueilli 23 2 54% des
voix pour ce qui est du gouvernement
marc heno le ministre de l'agriculture
il arrive en tête lui et lui aussi au
premier tour dans la première cercle si
dans la première circonscription du lot
reichert pardon avec 31 97 % des voix et
il affrontera lui aussi le candidat du
ps reda belkadi au second tour on l'a
dit tout à l'heure c'est l'une des
informations de la soirée jean-michel
bancaire l'ancien ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui lui est
éliminée dès le premier tour dans le
loiret il arrive en troisième position
derrière bruno notin le candidat de
l'ani baisse est derrière le candidat du
rassemblement national un autre grand
perdant de la soirée c'est eric zemmour
l'ancien candidat à l'élection
présidentielle qui ne parvient pas à se
hisser pour le second tour il recueille
23 points 10 9% des voix ça c'est dans
la 4e circonscription du var même sort
pour stanislas rigaud le jeune un
représentant du parti de reconquête il
lui aussi est éliminé dans la 2e
circonscription du vaucluse avec 10 54%
des voix et une dernière information
vincent brune ces manuels bon par
l'ancien directeur de campagne de jean
luc mélenchon et qui lui serait arrivé
largement en tête du premier tour ça
c'est dans la 4e circonscription est des
bouches du rhône ils recevraient 52 9%
des voix ça ce sont des estimations de
l'ifop
li merci timothée avec wii avec beaucoup
d'abstention comme on l'a dit tout à
l'heure dans cette circonscription des
bouches du rhône il ya une question qui
découle un petit peu de ça qu'est ce qui
va se passer que vont faire les
électeurs lrm et les électeurs de droite
quand il y aura des duels et reines du
ps comment vous analyser ça alors déjà
la question a été posée à la porte
parole du gouvernement où il vit à
grégoire qui était sur le plateau de
france 2 tout à l'heure pour l'asseoir
électorale voilà un peu en touche
aladino non je crois juste que ce sont
des débats locaux en tout cas ce n'est
pas ce soir un enjeu national mais la
question il faut quand même la pause et
guillaume bernard je suis parfaitement
d'accord avec vous c'est à dire que en
fait on retrouve le même type de deux si
tu que lorsque l'on avait des
triangulaires et qui était
la question était de savoir est ce que
le candidat qui peut se maintenir parce
qu'il fait douze ennemis d au minimum
douze ennemis des inscrits est ce qu il
le fait au risque entre guillemets de
faire gagner un candidat du
rassemblement national bon ben écoutez
là on se retrouve devant la même
situation où on peut aussi bien posé la
question je dirai à heller em qu'à
quelques à la nuque c'est à dire que
effectivement que font-ils lorsque et
bien un candidat du rassemblement
national il ya petit la conscription
miliana quand même un certain nombre est
en passe de sus de la gagner est ce que
il pratique le front républicain est ce
qu ils font le désistement est ce qu'ils
appellent à voter ou pas moi sincèrement
je ne sais pas ce qui va être donné
comme ce qui va doit être donné comme
consigne mais il me semble que c'est un
enjeu est effectivement important non
pas
alors je n'ai pas entendu par nos dix
mois mais bon là pour le coup je vais
moins manger à présidentiel auquel voir
ben d'accord donc ça veut dire que ça
veut dire sauf qu'à ce qu'ils ont dit
sur l'abstention le vote blanc bon lab
sociaux en règle générale elle profite
quand même plutôt celui qui est en panne
et c'est pas bon
[Musique]
voilà moi je pense que ça démontre une
chose c'est que la nuque ce est dans une
position qui est à la fois ce soir
extrêmement positif parce qu'ils vont
être présents dans de près 500 le second
tour et mais d'un autre côté cette nulle
ce et une est un cartel électoral qui à
mon sens n'a pas d'avenir politique
parce qu'il n'ya pas de cohésion
idéologique qui leur permettrait de
pérenniser d'être une force politique
pérenne dans l'est sur les réseaux
sociaux on voit un petit peu pointe et
on voit brûler les comportements des as
raison c'est ce que je vous disais les
gens qui se réjouissent la nuque qui
croient et qui essaie de mobiliser de
nouveau et il ya les électeurs de droite
qui lorsqu'il n'y a plus de candidats
aient l'air se disent la question ne se
pose même pas bien évidemment il faut
voter pour ensemble et pour la majorité
présidentielle
et je ne sais pas quel sera des
consignes là pour le coup
des politiques mais les
citoyens par des gens qui s'expriment
eux n'hésitent à 10 ans de toute façon
il n'est pas question de se laisser
passer la nuit c'est le phénomène un peu
quand même de la soirée gala c'est quand
même l'appel à l'abstention généralisée
et à chaque fois mais sinon je sais pas
si c'est un appel à l'abstention moi je
m'attendais jamais à chacun se sente si
j'ai pas entendu ce que disait ce que
vous
mais je suis pas étonné c'est que ce que
je m'attendais vraiment à ce que cette
question centrale là la réponse c'est à
dire en gros c'est jean luc mélenchon
qu'il ya et la chose face à marine le
pen à une présidentielle de dire pas une
voix au rassemblement national alors
c'est pas tout à fait abstentions ou
votes blancs c'est ça signifie ni
moi je vous donne pas de consigne de
vote en revanche je vous dis ne pas pas
ne pas faire et en l'occurrence ne
votaient pas pour le rassemblement
national et cette consigne elle va
s'appliquer probablement c'est ce que je
pressentais mais j'ai pas entendu de
d'éléments j'étais sur la route
à mon avis elle va s'appliquer dans bien
des cas de figure la république en
marche ensemble quand ils auront à
arbitrer parce qu'ils sont le troisième
un duel entre et rennes et du ps comme
dans du ps qui est un conglomérat il ya
les insoumis mais il ya aussi le ps est
aussi des partis de gouvernement dont
est issu emmanuel macron et une partie
des membres du gouvernement je pense
qu'ils ne peuvent pas complètement les
renvoyer dos à dos et je pense qu'ils ne
peuvent pas non plus appelé clairement à
voter pour les uns et les autres et ça
va se passer de la même manière
probablement pour les élèves sachant que
j'ai entendus pour le coup que jacob
avait dit qu'il voulait être constructif
nous semble-t-il
je pense qu'à se prépare à jouer le juge
de paix et à pouvoir ici ou là quand
même donner le petit coup de le petit
coup de pouce qu'il faudra lorsqu'en
plus un adversaire ps affrontera un
ensemble candidat de la majorité et que
ce n'est pas ce sera issu des insoumis
devons aussi regarder cela au règlement
nous est ce qu'on a à faire un hub s1
soumis ou un hub est socialiste fusent
comme vous avez vous demandé
mais elle sait ce qu'il va voir
justement un comportement différencier
des halles rer d à l'erreur des
électeurs et les roms qui se retrouvent
dans une circonscription où c'est un
défi face à un rassemblement national
c'est un peu différent que certains
socialistes y en avoir
enfin il ya trois niveaux de lecture il
ya vraiment l'électeur extrêmement
affûté qui va considérer que là c'est
pas possible parce que c'est un et les
finis que si ça avait été un écologiste
à la rigueur mais surtout électeurs le
plus le plus fréquent je pense que est
mort à des électeurs qui vont entendre
c'est pour ça que ces questions de
consignes sont importantes mais c'est
pas exclu qu effectivement il y ait des
modulations des consignes données par
nom par les états majors mais les
candidats battus localement en fonction
de qui est en présence second tour leur
histoire leur passé leurs partenaires
partners sur cette question des
conseillers ça fait partie aussi des
tests pour la nuit baisse parce que pour
le coup ça qui est dit pas une voix ne
brille une peine maintenant aubry oui
les filles donc aligné avec jean luc
mélenchon qui a disent la même chose
pour marine le pen et sauf que anne
hidalgo battue avait dit voter macro
tout cas il faut soutenir entre marine
le pen et que yannick jadot battu à dix
à la shoah d'ambiguïté donc je serais
assez étonné que toute la nuit ps parle
d'une seule voix nationalement et
localement en cas de duel elle est reine
dans une certaine si c'est le livre
c'est juste notre fragilité de la nuit
parce qu'on l'a pas évoqué parce qu'il
ya celle-ci effectivement ce que vous
disiez aussi sur l'aspect conglomérat et
l'autre fragilité c'est aussi lié à leur
force père que s'ils font un aussi bon
score dès le premier tour c'est parce
qu'ils ont du coup très peu de réserves
de voix au second tour c'est aussi pour
ça que il faut il faut regarder les
projections en sièges actuels mais il
faudra surtout regarder celle qu'on fera
sur la base du résultat du premier tour
en intégrant cette dimension d'absence
totale de réserve de voix pour la nuit
baisse alors qu il peut y en avoir un
petit peu pour pour la république en
marche alors il ya claude juste quinze
qui nous suit depuis le début dans le
chat du figaro.fr et on le remercie qui
nous dit en gros si j'ai bien compris et
vous allez confierons pas l'abstention
profita matheron
vous êtes d'accord avec cette formule
alors c'est pas évident c'est dire que
c'est un peu compliqué ce que je vais
dire je vais moi même
ici il arrive donc si on te comprends
très bien il a raison au sens
sociologique du terme l'abstention elle
est très marquée chez les catégories de
population qui sont des catégories de
population qui votent davantage nubes ou
rnb qui votent très peu ou beaucoup
moins pour emmanuel macron et pour
ensemble mais il ya eu un tel engouement
pour nous j'ose dire pour nous une
baisse de la part en tout cas des gens
qui suivaient cela que l'électorat
populaire et jeunes qui s'est mobilisée
la minorité d'électeurs populaire et
jeunes qui s'est mobilisée finalement a
pu profiter a dû annuler c'est peut-être
qu'ils ont réussi à compenser
probablement ont-ils réussi à compenser
cette fragilité sociologique parce que
sinon ils andry n'en serait pas là avec
un électorat aussi typé s'il n'avait pas
su convaincre quelques jeunes et
quelques catégories populaires de voter
pour eux on n'aurait pas ces résultats
là ils seraient 10 points derrière et le
score du rassemblement national il faut
peut-être l'évoqué à l'instant ils font
19%
avec 23 et demi à la présidentielle en
règle générale entre une présidentielle
et des lignages de décoder beaucoup plus
de ce que disait qu'il ya derrière moi
j'ai entendu parler de ce que disait
emmanuel c'est que c'est
un record pour le voilà ça c'est à dire
là il fait mal car moins d'un quart
alors que d'habitude ils perdent 1
d'hier de leur pourcentage et c'est
effectivement un bon résultat et ont
tout en ayant cherché on l'a bien
compris a tué reconquête ce qu'ils ont
quasiment régir tous bien réussi
l'opération soit réparé à mort y at il
des candidats ou candidates élues au
premier tour nous demande cet internaute
et avant que vous partiez
véronique g je me désole tellement doit
de départ mais heureusement victoire
bord il va au succès des on va pas
prendre de place et
on a dit dans le sondage
ban aux hawks à bakbone de la fin de
semaine que les faits divers à les
rentrer en tous les cas étaient allait
être déterminant dans le vote est ce que
quand on regarde ces résultats on peut
dire est ce que cette prédiction s'est
vérifiée ou pas
je sais pas si on a pas déjà fait des
retards dans le vase on a dit qu'il ya
pour un tiers des électeurs pardon mais
pour un tiers des électeurs les
différents faits divers que nous avons
testé 2 et oui ça comptera dans mon vote
je pense que le pouvoir d'achat la
question des retraites ont davantage en
jeu mais on a testé ça et c'est
justement parce qu'une campagne qui
n'accroche pas qu'ils ne marchent pas
qui n'a pas passionné sera question
c'est est pas question moi je te laisse
sur et enfin en soit
le commentaire du relais je ne suis pas
sûr que c'est joué par contre je suis
certaine que oui les jeannois on aura le
détail demain mais quand je regarde la
mobilisation qui avait pour duper
c'était un vrai sujet et il ya un fait
divers qui a quand même c'est pas que
ç'a influencé mais ça n'a fait que
conforter leur mobilisation santé plus
ce qu'ils étaient le stade de france
nettement le fait divers qui a le plus
mobilisé qui va continuer à mobiliser
parce qu'il ya une logique de
feuilletons nage donc on peut pas dire
que c'est ça qui a fait gagner mais
c'est ça qui a sans doute renforcé de
mobilisation qui était déjà assez
humbles et nu parce que j'en ai murray
s'était de plus à dire que ça compterait
dans leurs bottes et pour ne pas
répondre à la question vous connais pas
l'heure actuelle des lieux du premier
tour il y en avait que 4 milliards il ya
cinq ans donc il y en aura sans doute un
ou deux absents tueront oui c'est
l'effet attention bien sûr on peut avoir
plus de 50 pour
être dans il faut être unis dès le
premier tour avec une belle marge aura
dans une circonscription on a bien voté
et une quatre députés qui avaient été un
cette situation il ya cinq ans dans un
paris
et un autre one en bretagne peuvent
alors mollahs qui d'autre yann favennec
serait réélu dès le premier tour dans la
troisième circonscription de la mayenne
à vérifier mais bon j'en serai le
problème est qu'il peut y avoir aussi
les personnalités dont leurs racines mon
local fait que
lorsqu'il ya une circonscription qui est
pas forcément trop politisé ils peuvent
effectivement être susceptible de
l'emporter c'était pas le cas en 2010
est pas forcément les personnalités de
2017 qui ont été éludées premier tour
mais il peut y avoir des cas de ce type
de ce type généralement pour le coup
plutôt des des candidats certes marqué
dans un camp politique mais plutôt sans
étiquette ou divers droite ou divers
gauche
juste avant qu'on lance peut-être une
déclaration la déclaration de marine le
pen qui ont qu'on a écouté tout à
l'heure en direct sur le web on ne sait
pas vraiment faim visiblement il y
aurait un député élu dès le premier tour
en tout cas on sait qu'il ya beaucoup de
deux personnalités deux figures qui ont
été éliminés dès ce premier tour on
disait tout à l'heure jean michel
blanquer a éliminé dès le premier tour
mais aussi eric zemmour candidat à la
présidentielle guillaume
5e parce qu'autant le score dés et moore
il est ric-rac il arrive troisième avec
au-dessus de 20% au tendon sentié
s'effondra y arrive 5e et deux figures
de des républicains aussi des députés
sortants dont guillaume larrivé dans
l'yonne qui a été battu dès le premier
tour ainsi que julien aubert dans le
vaucluse éliminée dès le premier tour
également
on va écouter donc comme je vous l'avais
dit une réaction de marine le pen
dimanche prochain il est important de ne
pas laisser emmanuel macron disposer
d'une majorité absolue dont il abusera
pour appliquer ces méthodes autocentré
est brutal et nous imposer son projet
antisocial faire ce qu'il veut comme il
veut à votre place mais sans vous et
souvent contre vous si vous laissez
faire nous risquons d'entrer pour cinq
ans dans un tunnel un tunnel sans
lumière pour une majorité de français
cette situation sera peu respirable avec
des dizaines d'élus rassemblement
national vous aurez au contraire la
certitude d'être représentées par des
députés proches de vous une opposition
ferme mais respectueuse de nos
institutions et qui porte avec courage
un projet de redressement pour le pays
et pour le peuple dans les
circonscriptions qui voit au second tour
un duel entre la république en marche et
la nuque baisse javid les électeurs à ne
pas choisir entre les destructeurs d'en
haut et les destructeurs d'en bas
à ne pas choisir entre ceux qui veulent
vous priver de vos droits et ceux qui
veulent vous priver de vos biens la
france n'est ni une salle de marché nine
zad dans le cas où un candidat autre que
le rassemblement national ferait face à
un candidat lrm ou nubes j'invite les
électeurs à agir en conscience en
fonction du sens patriotique de ce
candidat
électeurs du rassemblement national
électeurs patriotes de droite de gauche
et d'ailleurs ayez conscience que la
séquence électorale n'est pas fini vous
avez un rôle essentiel à jouer vous
pouvez faire entrer à l'assemblée un
groupe national très importants comme
jamais dans l'histoire politique de
notre pays jusqu'à la une immense
victoire pour le corps national pour le
peuple et pour la france cette victoire
du corps national est à portée de main
et de vote je compte sur vous vive la
république vive la france
la victoire du camp national et pas
porter de vote finalement marine le pen
s'est réveillé c'est ça en avant l'
senti un petit peu endormi depuis la
présidentielle et l'alien il ya une
forme de réveil alors la victoire du
camp national enfin probablement parle
alors le coup au soir aucun avenir au
terme de vos seins street eut aucun
nouveau sondage j'ai lu attentivement
nos leprévost non il est même le
résultat de ce soir est encore une fois
c'est un premier tour mais malgré tout
dit quand même des choses alors c'est un
bon score pour le rassemblement national
comparez vous l'avez dit l'un et l'autre
effectivement au différentiel qui lit
habituellement entre présidentielle et
législatives il serait présent dans 150
à 200 circonscription pour le second
tour c'est pas c'est pas rien c'est pas
mal et effectivement c'est un parti qui
peut avoir des votes concentrés dans des
zones où il est très fort maintenant
c'est aussi un parti qui est
classiquement celui qui a toujours le
plus souffert de ce système de ce
système majoritaire et de cette absence
de proportionnelle aux législatives
et donc est ce que ça le conduire à
avoir une vingtaine de députés une
trentaine on verra mais on peut pas
parler grande victoire mais ce qui est
étonnant c'est que c'était elle la
deuxième de la présidentielle c'est elle
qui était en finale c'est elle qui est
amélioré très largement son score de
second tour par rapport à il ya cinq ans
et elle a laissé jean luc mélenchon
finalement être celui qui promettait des
des jours heureux à son camp
c'est surprenant elle aurait pu sans
doute faire encore mieux marine le pen
on accueille victor boribon soir qui
nous asseoir sur le plateau de bakbone
coutts ulti une première réaction peut
être sur les réseaux de cette soirée qu
est ce qui ressort un petit peu à l'aca
se confie ça confirme ce que véronique
précises avancé qui est assez peu de
messages peu peu d'engagement peu
d'émotion à part éventuellement quelques
commentaires à charge sur les
éliminations sur l'élimination d'eric
zemmour ou sur les ministres mais mis en
difficulté l'ancien
de réagir et surtout ça reste à un
niveau régional on voit assez peu
d'engagement sur sûr au niveau local non
c'est ce qui rend ce soit peut-être une
question sur sur provenir sur le
rassemblement national emmanuel
notamment on voyait quand même on disait
tout à l'heure que s'était concentré
quand même j'ai l'impression en
regardant quelques résultats ce soir que
l'inde est l'une des nouveautés c'est
qu'on voit une présence du rassemblement
national
dans des circonscriptions de l'ouest de
la france et dans l'ouest qui était
généralement je vois notamment 2e
circonscription de charente de était
quand même plutôt rétifs ce vote là
historiquement oui mes chansons et les
terres de conquête qui reste des terres
les conquêtes après rassemblement
national a progressé
le long de la garonne notamment trop sur
l'année des élections dans le golfe de
garonne entre de présence dans trois
circonscriptions alors lot-et-garonne
c'est pas nouveau dans le tarn et
garonne c'est pas nouveau c'était déjà
le cas il ya cinq ans avec des des
progressions puis ça s'est confirmé au
moment de la présidentielle sur deux
départements qui avaient placé marine le
pen en tête au second tour la charente
c'est un peu plus nouveau après ya
effectivement dans dans l'ouest qui
quand même très majoritairement une
terre plutôt hostile au rassemblement
national des poches comme ça selon les
cas le médoc notamment fait partie de
ces endroits qui ont souvent une
caractéristique commune un territoire
très enclavé avec très peu de connexions
avec la grande métropole qui et qui
pourtant pour tout proche et très
favorable à ce sentiment de relégation
qui est un des vecteurs durable du vote
pour le rassemblement national on a une
idée ce soir 2 qui a voté quoi de jade
en sont les premières premiers éléments
le premier sondage qui montre la
sociologie des électorats la géographie
selector il faut être un petit peu
patient faudra attendre alors peut-être
que certains confrères sur d'autres
soirées électorales dévoile déjà leurs
premières études mais nous nous elles
sont dans les tuyaux donc on pourra vous
le dire précisément on devrait pas avoir
de grandes surprises par rapport à ce
qu'on avait observé au niveau
sociologique en tout cas lors de la
présidentielle et puis qui correspondent
à des fondamentaux importants et qu'on
retrouve le la carte de cette élection
c'est à dire des catégories populaires
qui vont se répartir essentiellement
entre un vote tenu baisse et un vote et
rennes notamment à votre buzz quand
elles sont plusieurs bennes à voter
rennes lorsqu'elles sont plus
périurbaines ou rurales et des
catégories plus aisées bourgeois des
entrées et des centres villes qui qui
vont davantage voté pour ensemble voir
un petit peu pour air dont on a peu
parlé mais qui finalement se maintient
et en tout cas il y fait un petit peu
oublié le score calamiteux de la
présidentielle c'est une des questions
est subsidiaire serre que est ce que le
score de l air qui déclame nettement
supérieur à celui de valérie pécresse en
pourcentage lors de cette élection
estimations d'animation donne aux
alentours de 10 ans pour cent
et le le résultat de la
sur-représentation peut-être de
certaines catégories de la population
dans le box parle ici notamment aux
retraités et la surreprésentation
d'autres et d'autres catégories vous
parlez des 18-34 ans c'est aussi le fait
que c'est pas le même scrutin oui du
coup il n'y a pas la même notion vote
utile par exemple disparaît à peu près
complètement dans un scrutin qui par
circonscription donc les électeurs
quelques exceptions près pas vraiment
micro exception ne savent pas du tout
qui tourne peut-être qui part en tête
dans les sondages après sondages dans la
circonscription donc ils votent en
fonction de ce qu'ils connaissent et
parce qu'il ya quand même un certain
contrôle le guillou bernard de vases
communicants entre la république en
marche et elle est restée très tentant
de se dire que si on totalise heures et
avec un toute participation très
différents donc
relativiser cette comparaison ans mais
si on totalise total macron et pécresse
du premier tour la présidentielle et le
total et lèvres m heller du premier tour
des législatives
eh bien on a à peu près sur la même par
l'électorat français jouent alors il ya
quand même un autre élément aussi c'est
que vous pouvez avoir tout simplement
des députés sortants wii ou des
personnalités qui n'ont pas été élus
députés mais qui sont connus au niveau
local ne peuvent tout simplement faire
des scores qu'on ne faut pas négliger le
fait que venir il n'y a pas dans le
personnel politique que des ténors
nationaux il ya quand même aussi un
certain nombre de personnes alors celle
au niveau local c'est là dit il est sûr
que le les dispositions législatives
concernant la limitation du nombre de
mandats et la compatibilité des mandats
nationaux et locaux ne favorise pas
la présence je dirais d'un député maire
ou d'un des coûts des sénateurs ce qui
auparavant étaient beaucoup plus clair
beaucoup plus simple voilà il ya quand
même des personnalités locales
contribuent à faire que l air soit un
score double de celui de valérie
pécresse ya seulement 100 députés
sortants aient l'air et on a quand même
un sport de 21 ans et demi la dernière
fois aux dernières législatives pour à
l'air ok il y avait ce soir là il ya une
dizaine de points kory teneycke
ça vient confirmer dans l'analyse qu'on
fait des réseaux sociaux a confirmé ces
éléments à savoir que depuis plusieurs
semaines dans tous les messages et
volume de messages échangés on voit très
faible connaissance des enjeux du
scrutin est la plupart du temps
notamment chez les plus jeunes
méconnaissance de deux qui sont leurs
candidats ou leurs élus actuels
si vous nous rejoignez nous sommes en
direct maintenant depuis 19h sur
lefigaro.fr et sur notre page youtube
figaro live pour suivre les résultats de
ce premier tour des élections
légistatives 2022 et les commenter avec
nos regards extérieurs politologue des
sondeurs mais aussi d'ici une heure les
plumes du figaro restez bien avec nous
pour découvrir la une de votre journal
demain alexis brézet viendra nous l'a
présentée en direct en attendant on va
faire un point complet sur les dernières
infos les déclas les appels à ralliement
avec d'autres mais carragher tout à fait
daphné a souhaité à vous et à tous les
deux alors tout d'abord eric zemmour
candidats reconquête a été limé éliminé
pardon au premier tour pour lui les
résultats ne sont pas à la hauteur de
nos attentes mais nous venons de poser
un drapeau dans chaque circonscription
du côté des l air le président des
républicains christian jacob estime que
le score du parti est moins dur que
prévu jean françois copé sur france
inter assure lui que c'est une famille
politique qui va devoir se reconstruire
intégralement
il temporise en rappelant que l'histoire
de france nous a appris que les
rebondissements étaient innombrables du
côté de la majorité amélie de mon
challenge ministre de la transition
écologique revient sur l'abstention et
les raisons qui permettraient
d'expliquer ce chiffre record il faut
arriver à mobiliser les français afin
qu'ils aillent aux urnes il faut
convaincre et montrer la pertinence de
notre projet fin de citation et sur
bfmtv c'est clément bonne qui s'est
expliqué à propos de la nuque ps pour
lui jean luc mélenchon dit élisez moi
premier ministre mais il n'est pas
candidat il ne sera ni élu ni premier
ministre et pour finir du côté de la
gauche jean-luc mélenchon a assuré que
la nouvelle l'union populaire arrive en
tête elle sera présente dans plus de 500
circonscription au deuxième tour voilà
ce que l'on pouvait dire à 10 heures
merci daphné d'ailleurs de clément boon
qui devrait pourrait réagir en tout cas
ce sera à vivre sur le figaro live donc
le ministre délégué à l'europe qui est
arrivé
d'une courte quand il n'est pas en tête
c'est la nuque mais ce qui est arrivé
dans sa circonscription à paris mais il
se qualifie tout de même pour le second
tour il arrive juste derrière avec 34 7%
des suffrages un second tour qui risque
d'être difficile
à mettre en partie d'ailleurs des points
un peu symbolique lien procès molik delà
du premier tour qui pas encore tranché
et c'est qui est en tête entre la nuit
ps et la république en marche et il y
aura un autre élément symbolique est ce
qu'il ya des ministres sur le carreau
dire qu'ils sont oubliés le gouvernement
d'avoir réussi à confirmer dans leur
circonscription à construire
construction vous avez pris le risque de
présenter parce qu'il ya manque tous les
membres du gouvernement n'était pas
candidat
une quinzaine de membres deux ministres
sont pour l'instant candidats alors pour
l'instant même on rappelle que la
plupart d'entre eux sont plutôt bien
placés 1 olivier dussopt pts
30 0 4% dans la 2e circonscription de
l'ardèche face à la nuque baisse 7
points quasiment devant delà du ps marc
fesneau
31,97 ballottage favorable également
dans la première du loir-et-cher est
également un ballottage favorable mais
plus difficile de franck riester en
seine et marne 28 48% et 26 54% et puis
et puis il ya damien abad qui devance
quand même pour l'instant de 10 points
le son adversaire delà du ps c'est dans
la 5e circonscription non ça sera une
élection qui devait être une des
élections qui a capitulé oui sans que ce
soit non plus une si grande surprise que
ça alors il ya eu à ma connaissance de
ce sondage dans cette circonscription je
les ai pas vus mais on est dans une
circonscription dans laquelle il n'est
pas présent depuis longtemps qui est
ancré pour lui et il y à une fidélité
des électeurs on le sait c'est une
figure connue qui l'a été encore plus du
coup avec sa visibilité subies ces
derniers jours donc c'était regardez
c'est pas si étonnant on a déjà vu
d'autres hommes politiques frappées par
des polémiques plus ou moins lourdes qui
ont été absous finalement par paris les
électeurs et par le suffrage électoral
henri emmanuelli bon notamment pas que à
queue alors parmi les candidats éliminés
dès le premier tour il ya une figure
médiatique en tout cas un people comme
on dit francis lalanne qui a été élevé
mais éliminé dès le premier tour il
était candidat en charente dans la
troisième circonscription et l'a
recueilli seulement 2,2 pour cent des
voix 2 % des voix pour pour francis
lalanne est donc le duel sera pérenne
ensemble
il ya quelque chose pensable important
de l'avoir en tête c'est que les
résultats du second tour sont dans une
liste relative sont pas l'arithmétique
du premier tour il ya cinq ans il ya eu
des miraculés lr notamment qui était
très très très très mal parti au soir du
premier tour largement devancé et parce
que les électeurs peuvent aussi opérer
une espèce de réajustement alors là on a
un peu en terre inconnue comme on se
disait tout à l'heure c'est la première
fois qu'on a des circonstances comme ça
président réélu avec des candidats qui
font moins de 30% donc on ne sait pas
s'il y aura justement ni dans quel sens
mais
voilà ce qu'ils sont en tête même avec
10 points peuvent pas considérer comme
assurer leur réélection surtout je suis
tout à fait décorer pénal mais surtout
si les l'inégalité entre la nuque ps et
ensemble si nous sommes dans une
circonscription où on a finalement
ensemble et la nuit parce qu'ils te
retrouves au second tour il y aura plus
de réserves de voix potentielles des
candidats plus à droite ensemble pour
aller vers ensemble que pour aller vers
la nuque baisse donc il faut que la du
ps est un avantage à priori malgré
toutes les incertitudes évoquées jeu j'y
souscris il faut que la nuque baisse est
un avantage un peu conséquent quand même
parce que en cas d'égalité stricte
normalement mathématiquement c'est plus
favorable ensemble
christian jacob le président des
républicains ce vient de s'exprimer je
vous propose de l'écouter et on voit
bien que on est en situation de jouer un
rôle déterminant dans cette législature
entre la voie des extrêmes et
l'immobilisme
conduit par là la majorité du président
mâcon nous seront constructifs nous
voterons les textes qui vont dans le bon
sens nous opposerons durement lorsque ça
ne sera pas le cas et surtout ce que
j'espère est ce que je demande aux
français aujourd'hui c'est de nous faire
confiance parce que nous nous pourrons
faire bouger les choses nous ne sommes
pas pour la révolution permanente
nous ne sommes pas pour le matraquage
des classes moyennes au contraire pour
que ce pays se réforme ça ressemble un
peu à une offre de services
but we saw alors en tout cas ça
ressemble à un constat objectif d'une
situation c'est quand même le paradoxe
de notre système vous avez un parti qui
réussit moins bien que la gauche dans
ces législatives dans ce premier tour
c'est le moins qu'on puisse dire est
qu'ils se retrouvent dans une position
un poil sup avec un poids bien supérieur
et donc c'est à la fois un constat
réaliste pragmatique et ça ressemble
aussi à une petite proposition peut être
un des centres on verra
c'est cette fois des partis charnières
voilà c'est à dire que vous pouvez peser
2 % au niveau national
mais si vous avez une implantation
locale qui vous permet d'avoir des élus
dans la pénombre de circonscription vous
peser énormément c'est le cas du parti
radical de gauche qui pèsent au niveau
national très peu mais qui a des élus et
qui est toujours partie prenante dans
les gouvernements de gauche
qui ont pu exister
sous la vème république alors sous des
républiques précédentes évidemment
beaucoup plus et là il pesé évidemment
énormément voilà
donc dans une multitude de démocratie
parlementaire en
allemagne c'est le cas de tous ces
partis charnières qui finissent par
constituer des majorités
et l'air et peut espérer survivre parce
qu'on l'avait enterré
avec la présidentielle mais comme l air
avait des élus locaux
mais que les élections locales havas a
des élus locaux et que les élections
locales n'auront lieu qu'après la
prochaine présidentielle c'est donc un
parti qui va continuer à exister et donc
on peut penser que s'il arrive à sauver
quand même un nombre assez conséquent
d'élus ils pourront peut-être essayer de
pas simplement je dirais de vivoter mais
d'essayer de reconstituer une force
politique d'autant que leur principal
concurrent qui est reconquête semble
dans une mauvaise posture donc par
conséquent effectivement
les dirigeants de l air vont devoir se
poser la question est ce qu'on est une
force supplétive s'est dit de manière un
peu péjoratif je le reconnais de l air m
ou est ce que on essaye de se droitiser
et d'essayer de reconquérir si vous
permettez l'expression l'électorat à
l'électorat zemmour hier
ça commence à veauche réseaux sociaux on
voit qu'elle est les militants du ps ont
saisi l'enjeu sur le second tour à
savoir le risque de vote utile qui
pèsent sur cette même circonscription et
donc une forte mobilisation notamment
sur twitter pour continuer à mobiliser
tout le long de la semaine jusqu'au
jusqu'au prochain tôt alors que
l'odieuse 15 juste qui réagit sur le
chat à la déclaration de christian jacob
qui dit cela s'appelle je cite de la
lèche politique et après vous vous
indignez de l'abstention on va tout de
suite faire un décrochage vers un autre
studio du figaro le studio piles et will
ou un autre direct a lieu en ce moment